et si moi je disais si vous disiez pas
ici de dire ami de la maman avoue par
exemple 1 2 3 bonsoir de moi c'est moins
trois ans
quatre mois
on va on va rester comme on était amis
le noir bien mais je dois tout le monde
en parle et michel guibal avait vu se
doit
[Musique]
bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non non non
à
sur le plateau de tout le monde en plein
l'émission qui parle avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
l'ex-conseiller d'europe 1
jean michel jarre est sympa
jamie en toi
horrifiée
yves le gall on est passé l'argent nuit
sous la nuit
et
la chance sur l'avenue
la soeur de john lennon the blind test
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va merci pour cet accueil chaleureux
bien plus d'aplomb maintenant non mais
je crois que les gens vont jouer à ma
juste valeur c'est bon ça va et toi tu
irais mais ça va c'est toi qui vas pas
la cause de si ça va j'ai perdu un match
de tennis à ce qui fait dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que au tournoi des
personnalités à roland garros
laurent s'est fait torcher pierre sled
ouais bah oui en demi-finale ça fait la
troisième fois deuxième train qui me
semble oui il est beaucoup plus fort que
moi voilà voilà
cela dit j'ai repéré le joueur qui
allait gagner le tournoi des
personnalités et même plus peut-être
même roland garros j'ai découvert un
joueur incroyable c'est qui serge
khalfon mesdames messieurs
ils jouent bien serge non mais tu sais
un peu zappé déjà démontré sa photo ap
si on en parle toujours on le voit
jamais plaisir la gueule alors de
m'envoyer des petites de france 2 point
fr tu parle anglais glace commandites ou
en anglais ma belle-mère ne viendra pas
dîner ce soir
my mother in lowan comme ford gina
tonight
non on dit yes moitié répond ouais et
c'est un couple qui a une petite blague
c'est un couple qui baise et la lafa
médias son mari chéri dix mois des trucs
salle et lui dit le salon le garage
d'achat
dominique ambiel
non
pour toi quant à binic bienvenus on
sortirait alors dominique vous êtes né
le 6 juin 1954 à paris quand vous étiez
gosses vous rêviez de faire du cinéma de
la radio de la télévision de la chanson
mais vous commencez par être gaulliste à
asnières à l'âge de 15 ans que s'est il
passé
mais coûté à l'époque j'ai été très
marqué par le fait que ma maman qui
avait 20 ans au moment de la de la
guerre avait perdu fusillé à la cascade
du bois de boulogne
c'est plus cher ami cinq de ses
compagnons et 24 ans après alors que en
44 des jeunes mourrait pour leur patrie
les événements de mai 68 mais avait
heurté
je trouvais qu au fond c'était un peu
une révolution pour rien c'était presque
d etat d etat d'humeur et je me suis dit
à ce moment là certainement il ya des
choses il ya des aspirations mais ce que
ça justifie tout ça et j'ai à ce moment
là je suis devenu gaulliste alors à 20
ans vous êtes professeur de lettres au
collège sainte-croix de neuilly c'est
pas des lycées facile non plus on sera
collège de banlieue vie difficiles de
munich
parallèlement donc vous continuez votre
engagement en politique vous faites
partie des jeunes giscardiens pardon
mais ce n'est pas antinomique jeunes
giscardiens il ya pas lieu comme c'est
la question que michel rocard à l'époque
m'a posé des rêves a dit comment peut-on
être jeunes giscardiens et faire de la
politique autrement
eh ben on essayait qu'est ce qu'il a
fait jusqu'à quand même ils abaisser la
majorité à 18 ans il a fait il a
libéralisé l'avortement
il a fait la loi sur le divorce je vous
rappelle quand même qu'à 25 ans dans ce
pays on pouvait pas divorcer sauf pour
faute grave personne s'en souvient de sa
session sera donnée la sécurité sociale
aux artistes voilà donc il a fait de la
politique autrement
ouais voilà aidé à monter une petite
bijouterie pas mal et la valeur était
pas terrible
juste pour finir on s'est bien fait
chier avec lui quand même moi j'étais
adolescent sous giscard c'est pas drôle
qu'elle en hisser au delà de ça c'est
parce qu'il fallait venir aux jeunes
giscardiens alors ah oui c'est qu'on
soit bien
quand je savais qu'en plus des tétées
sympa avant ensuite vous quitter
l'enseignement pour ne plus faire que de
la politique
et vous n'abandonnez pas la politique
quand vous devenez directeur du
développement du société expand groupe
de télévision qui devient rapidement le
premier fournisseur des chaînes
françaises vous partiez de ce groupe
suite au rachat par vivendi via canal
pour devenir conseiller du premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin conseiller
pour la communication
et puis dans la nuit du 19 au 20 avril
2004 vous êtes victime de ce que vous
appelez dans votre livre une étrange
affaire
on vous accuse de fréquenter une jeune
prostituée roumaine
ce qui amène votre démission d'ailleurs
je dis d'ailleurs que thierry ardisson
me téléphonent ou m'écrit un mot tout de
suite mon téléphone mais ce un message
disant ça pue la merde oui absolument
effectivement et je crois avoir démontré
ça donc je vais pas y revenir non mais
simplement elle monte dans la voiture
c'est dur 18 secondes
je lui demande de descendre au feu rouge
suivant et à ce moment là il ya un
contrôle de police qui se passe tout à
fait bien puisqu'on dit qu' il n'y a
aucune infraction qu'il n'y a absolument
aucun problème et ça devient une affaire
d'état seulement 24 heures plus tard
voilà donc ceci entraîne votre démission
votre retour dans le giron de la
télévision et enfin je démissionne
j'avais décidé de reprendre mes
activités de production et édition le
1er juillet et pour ne pas gêner jean
pierre raffarin parce qu'elle s'était
naturellement pas moins la cible de mr
niel on n'avait pas pris le pantalon
décès dans une rue de paris
donc c'était pas c'était pas c'était pas
moi la cible c'était naturellement un
premier ministre cherche à l'atteindre
ont trouvé deux mois et donc je me suis
dit que partir tout de suite était la
meilleure façon de déconnecter la cible
et d'ailleurs ça a duré trois jours
après plus personne n'en a parlé absolue
le perron où j'étais plus que jean
perras fera plus personne intéressée
plus personne et j'ai donc pu diriger
dans cette production que je dirige
aujourd'hui avec six semaines d'avancé
par rapport au calendrier prévu voilà
alors le 24 mars 2005 publié chez plon
un livre qui s'appelle fort matignon où
vous donnez votre version de la sphère
où vous raconter les coulisses les
manipulations enfin bref la lave
à matignon alors ça c'est intéressant
vous vous dites raffarin le courage vous
pensez que c'est vraiment le mot qui
définit le mieux jean pierre raffarin
c'est le courage il a fait des réformes
que personne ne voulait faire les
retraites par exemple michel rocard
avait dit ça que celui qui s'attaquera à
la réforme des retraites
y'a de quoi faire tomber des
gouvernements raffarin l'a fait
j'appelle ça le courage mr raffarin qui
pourrait vous prendre des décisions en
piqué revenait après quelques jours plus
tard sur ses décisions sur les retraites
il est parvenu en arrière du tout sur
l'assurance maladie des parvenus en
retour en arrière du tout sur les
réductions d'impôts il peut revenir en
arrière du taux d'émission paquet
regretté sur la démission mais observer
la vie est longue
il a 56 ans donc il a un peu temps
devant lui mais je n'ose de cette
émission croyez-moi il l'a donné
plusieurs fois président de la
république et je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
est très heureux de pouvoir être anobli
brrr il voulait partir déjà depuis
longtemps
l'année dernière il avait des
coprésidents dit non tu restes tu es
obligé de rester mais parce qu'il est
loyal il est fidèle
il est courageux et loyal voilà ça me
rappelle une pub pour des croquettes
alors vous parlez dominique du courage
de raffarin des bourdes des ministres
alors ça vous dit qu'ils en font tous
notamment d'aller s'encanailler chez
ardisson et oui j'ai encore que c'était
prêcheur dix ans je crois que le
ministre de la justice était venue
chanter tata yoyo avec annie cordy mais
pas chez été c'est un concurrent à vous
raconter des trucs incroyables quand
même les interventions ou faisait quand
vous êtes tout à matignon par exemple si
un jour il ya l'express qui fait un
titre raffarin la faim et vous vous
appelez en demandant qu'on change le
titre je veux changer titre je pose la
question je dis attendez est-ce que
c'est pas bien on est en automne 2003 je
vous rappelle qu'il vient de quitter le
gouvernement on est en mai 2005 donc ils
avaient un peu d'avancé à la fin je dis
est ce que vous croyez pas que ça serait
bien quand même de poser la question
simplement
effectivement ils ont mis un point
d'interrogation ils ont eu raison mais
je pense que j'aurais rendu à grand fort
bien mais ça se passe comme ça c'est un
peu le conseiller en communication du
premier ministre le constructeur
propriétaire des journaux en dix ans
dites à vos journalistes de change en
titre de l'argent du tout pas du tout le
conseiller en communication du président
qui fait son boulot
ouais quand par exemple ou blanc la
canicule
une chaîne de télévision qui est celle
qu'elle nous sommes diffuse des images
du premier ministre en bras de chemise
dans les alpages avec des petites fiches
à la main ont été entonnés j'ai le
numéro de portable de ministre ou alors
qu'il ya 5000 morts similaire 7000 morts
huit mille morts qu'est ce qu'elle croit
madame michu leur mentent elles croient
cependant que c'est une hécatombe de
canicule prémices et en bras de chemise
dans les alpages mort ces images ont été
tournées
dix jours avant alors que la canicule
n'a pas commencé ça j'appelle ça de la
malhonnête ça ou le rôle et le job du
conseiller en communication du premier
ministre c'est à dire ça c'est pas mal
appelée l'express qui est un journal
indépendant qui appartient à monsieur
dassault pour qu'il change le titre mais
et quand monsieur colombani appelle le
premier ministre pour lui dire il
faudrait que les cinq cent mille euros
que on pourrait avoir pour éviter le
krach financier au bord duquel est vrai
que vous le débloquer tout de suite
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que j'en ai
le monde la wii le journal demande s'il
ya quinze jours trafic d influence
ils font tous un nom c'est pas du trafic
d'influencé c'est normal se dire les
hissent les lorsque lorsque patrons de
presse est en situation d équilibre il a
l'intérêt il a envie de sauver son
journal c'est normal et ça valait fait
feu de tout bois mais quand même vous
trouvez que c'est des méthodes sada
plongera l'indépendant vous trouvez ça
normal peut-être chez pinsent mais je
trouve normal de faire son métier
chacun fait son métier ils sont rangés
de vous écouter quand je devais dire
bien sûr mais c'est normal nous ont pas
complètement dégoûté ils ont bien un
point d'interrogation mais j'ai pas
demandé qu'ils disent pas rafa khalaf
moi j'ai dit est ce que vous croyez la
seule chose que j'ai faite c'est que
j'ai appelé rudi roussillon en effet
l'époque et je lui ai dit est ce que
vous trouvez normal d'écrire que
raffarin c'est fini est ce que vous
croyez que c'est vrai et si dans six
mois ou dans un an il est toujours prévu
c'est pourquoi est ce que vous croyez
qu'on fera on donnera une interview à
l'express tout c'est mon boulot c'est
mon job de faire ça tu pourrais nous
avoir la couverture de télé 7 jours
non je peut arranger ça alors vous
parlez de villepin dans votre bouquin
alors c'est drôle parce que c'est ce
dernier qui évidemment a été écrit avant
que dominique de villepin soit premier
ministre vous parler par exemple de la
sphère mari elle l'affabulatrice du rer
qui a fait croire à un attentat
antisémite ou trouvez qu'il a réagi
d'une façon un peu adolescente un peu
puéril non je sais je parle de pas mal
de manipulation dans ce livre et je
parle de des coulisses du pouvoir et
dans les coulisses du pouvoir il ya un
certain nombre d'acteurs qui ont parfois
des motivations qui sont très obscures
je ne suis pas sûr que les rapports qui
ont été donnés à dominique de villepin
alors qu'il était mis à l'intérieur
étaient des rapports extrêmement précis
et je ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs que lui
même on l'est pas conduit à faire ce
communiqué très rapidement trop
rapidement alors qu'en fait c'est une
affabulatrice car on a su depuis on a
appris depuis que très vite un certain
nombre de services de police croit de
justice aussi se doutait de de
l'affabulation
ouais mais on ne l'a pas dit apparemment
nous ça n'est pas remonté jusqu'aux
mises intérieur qui naturellement
conduit de l'émotion soulevée a fait le
communiqué qu'il a fait donc ce que vous
entendez là c'est qu'on essaye de le
planter en fait mais ça arrive tous les
jours les gens racontent plaindre il y
un plein plein bien alors
l'interpellation didier julia si vous
vous lui reprochez à villepin sont là
des policiers se présentent et le
demande de le suivre
didier julia il dit je suis député je
suis un inventaire des gentils messieurs
c'est quoi et donc ils les envoient
promener et voilà c'est tout et puis
aussi une attitude très anti-américaine
chez villepin
mais ça c'est sûr que dominique de
villepin a
un côté gaullien à côté résistant un
côté la france d'abord d'ailleurs ça ça
a été très important au moment de la
guerre en irak
ce qui est sûr c'est que tous les jours
on travaille et que les américains et
que aujourd'hui à washington les les
réactions à la nomination de milliers de
philippins sont pas forcément
enthousiasme et c'est pour ça que
nicolas sarkozy dans le gouvernement
parce que ça contrebalance parce qu'au
final finalement nicolas sarkozy c'est
la mise des américains ouais alors vous
citer une phrase de jacques chirac au
sujet de dominique de villepin dans
votre bouquin c'est toute façon on lit
le pain il change d'avis toutes les deux
heures
ben c'est pareil siparex qui l'a dit il
a dit ça oui mais l'écrire y est
maintenant là maintenant qu'il est
premier ministre que sur pourquoi
pourquoi faut avoir peur
non non faut pas avoir peur mais enfin
c'est pas très comme chirac ce comme le
grand soutien de villepin le fait qu'il
dise ça c'est pas énorme quand jacques
chirac il a des collaborateurs qu'il qui
vision fidel ne veulent pas être celui
là
et quand on a des collaborateurs qui
vous sont fidèles on connaît leurs
défauts et leurs qualités mais je trouve
ça quand même inquiétant il l'a nommé
premier ministre est quelqu'un dont ils
pensent qu'ils changent d'avis toutes
les deux heures c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur choix non il a un président il
ya un président de république
1 il ya un ministre d'état je crois que
ce sera un bon premier ministre villepin
sérieux écoutez je pense qu'il a le
panache et l'audace et
que surtout il à la loyauté vous dites
l'audace quand même excusez moi mais
sarko à l'intérieur douste-blazy au aux
affaires étrangères michèle alliot marie
à la défense
on n'est pas d'audace on prend les mêmes
et on recommence d'être d'accord il ya
des gens qui rendent des gens qui
sortent vous savez les gens qu'il change
quoi oui jean louis billon du parti oui
mais enfin bon c'est pas évident en
politique on est en plein dans la langue
de bois
non me blazy les médecins le fait qu'ils
soient à la santé ce n'était pas idiot
un hacker médecins nous affaires
étrangères était à la culture et la
communication est étranger aux affaires
n'ont cessé vous croyez pas que c'est
quelque chose que les gens comprennent
pas ça c'est à dire que les mecs passent
d'un ministère alloue ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas de compétences parce
que mais est ce moi je pourrais pas
animer une émission animalière qui
pourrait tirer ça dépend quel horaire et
quelques animaux mais je ne pensais pas
que ça participe au désamour des
français pour la politique de voir que
finalement on s'échange des ministères
comme ça que c'est pas très grave a
réagi la police et le rythme y crois
qu'il ya des compétences et je crois
qu'il y à une profession web et qui
contrairement à ce qu'on a ce qu'on dit
la politique c'est un métier et donc il
faut savoir construire il faut savoir
faire des projets de loi il faut savoir
diriger un ministère il faut savoir
maîtriser une administration et c'est
vrai aujourd'hui que quelqu'un comme
nicolas sarkozy à l'intérieur il a la
compétence
oui ça c'est sûr et compétents pour
diriger les flics c'est sûr qu'il a la
compétence mais un mec qui est médecin
le mettre à la santé c'est mieux que de
le mettre aux affaires étrangères non je
sais pas moi oui mais peut-être mais il
est aussi c'est un homme politique c'est
un homme nationale aujourd'hui ça va de
philippe douste-blazy c'est quelqu'un
qui quel sens du contact donc je dis
voilà il sait faire ça au final quand
dominique de villepin dit sur tf1 lors
de sa première allocution en parlant de
raffarin contre le chômage tout n'a pas
été fait est ce que vous pensez pas que
le fils de loyauté rompu justement c'est
pas très sympa dire ça sert à rien mais
c'est vrai que tout n'a pas été fait pas
très sympa quand même bien sûr mythe
mais rien fait de tout n'est pas fait
heureusement que tout n'est pas fait il
ya toujours des religions a tenté si
elle est d'ailleurs d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire une chose
lorsque
on oppose le modèle social le modèle de
lutte contre le chômage
de nicolas sarkozy à celui de dominique
de villepin
qu'est ce que ça veut dire il n'y a que
sur les plateaux télé qui a des top
models je veux dire en réalité est ce
qui est un modèle qui réussit partout
absolument en angleterre il ya un modèle
qui fait qu'à 5% de chômage soit dit un
modèle qui est complètement inverse qui
fait que les 4 % de chômage ouais donc
ça veut bien dire que il faut essayer
toutes les solutions les unes après les
autres les unes à côté des autres
donc voilà c'est tout mou n'a pas eu ça
fait quoi 30 ans qu'on essaye des
solutions là maintenant et bien sûr et
oui c'est chaque nouveau gouvernement
redéfinit les priorités c'est génial
un griot reategui parce que l'emploi
mais parce que la france est un pays qui
a peur de bouger qui a peur de changer
une peur du changement c'est vrai parce
que quand on change quand on change on
sait ce qu'on perd et on n'a pas
toujours conscience de ce qu'on va
gagner et ça effectivement c'est un vrai
problème c c c c est une espèce de statu
quo on a peur de bouger on a peur de
ceux de changer les habitudes sur le sur
les entreprises par exemple c'est ça
quand j'entends dire que les la
modification du code du travail risque
d'aboutir à du chômage c'est peut-être
vrai dans certaines grosses entreprises
multinationales mais dans une pme moche
dirige une pme
croyez-moi l'emploi dans une pme c'est
une fierté un donc sincèrement de dire
que en assouplissant les règles on va
provoquer du chômage c'est probablement
faux mais dire en même temps qu'on doit
tout ouvrir ouvrir toutes les vannes
c'est aussi dangereux et jura mais je
n'ai pas pensé que les bains m'est
arrivé mais thierry jean-pierre raffarin
il ya pensé puisque le plan de cohésion
sociale qui était mis en place par jean
louis borloo date de maintenant près
d'un an jean louis borloo qu'il a mis
cinq ans à valenciennes va pouvoir
réduire le chômage à le diviser par
trois ça ne se fait pas en un jour
c'est pas un coup de baguette magique
d'accord alors dans votre affaire là
dedans on parlait tout à l'heure quand
on va parler toute la soirée mais quand
même vous
dit que villepin n'a pas été étranger à
cette affaire mais j'explique ce stage
les expliquer vous lirez dans le livre
j'ai expliqué très précisément les
questions que je me pose son directeur
de cabinet qui ne me dit rien alors que
deux heures après je suis convoqué par
les flics
il m'a expliqué tout cela on s'est vus
on s'en est parlé
vous l'avez que j'ai cru ses
explications j'ai raison ou tort je ne
sais pas j'ai cru ses explications et
donc voila l affaire est close en ce qui
me concerne oui c'était un coup monté
non je propose qu'on en comptait 5 ou
exploités mais en tout cas c'est un
bouquin qui donne pas envie de s'arrêter
au feu rouge
ça fait froid dans le dos quand même
tiré alors dans votre bouquin vous
parlez d'une conversation entre
dominique de villepin donc à l'époque
ministre de l'intérieur et vie plenel
qui rédacteur en chef du journal le
monde au sujet de votre affaire vous
savez pas si c'est dominique de villepin
qui a appelé de vie plein m6 et le
diplôme elle qui a appelé dominique de
villepin je ne sais pas je vous en avais
parlé avec dominique de villepin
non non je n'ai pas parlé de ça avec
finit bien vous allez en parler c'est
une affaire qui est passé de points vous
l'avez soupçonné quand même un moment
villepin non je me suis posé la question
de savoir pourquoi alors qu' à rien les
rapports de police dise aucune
infraction d constaté devant l'absence
d'infraction caractérisée nous avons
invité à monsieur revel à repartir après
des vérifications d usage
je me demande pourquoi je suis convoqué
24 heures après par la police alors que
rien de se parler en général ccc ça
monte tout de suite par les deux heures
qui suivent s'il ya vraiment un problème
est que je déjeune extra tendres qui est
bien et qu'il ne me dit rien voilà bon
c'est vrai il m'a expliqué mme dunn
explications il m'a dit il m'a dit en
fait
quand il part pour déjeuner avec toi il
n'y a pas d'affaires la sphère démarre
après on me sert la justice voilà donc
cheveux et c'est vrai que j'ai insulté
les flics en disant tirez vous c'est moi
qui vous paye pas du tout non pas du
tout j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai été relaxé
d'un outrage à agent dire qu'on a
considéré qu'il n'y avait aucun propos
attentatoires à l'honneur limites parce
que ça n'arrive pas à 30 ans certains
policiers disent des choses que vous
leur dites et qui ne sont pas vraies non
moi j'ai confiance
non est ce que dominique de villepin
vous trouvez pas un peu trop ami avec
nicolas sarkozy
thierry ardisson j'ai moi militer à
l'époque pour ceux qu'on appelait la
guerre contre le tss 16 pouces
risque-t-elle pas un statut sarkozy tout
sauf sarkozy est à l'époque jean-pierre
raffarin avait dit moi je suis pour le
test des tout sauf la division alors je
vais pas pleurer c'est président de la
république a décidé de nommer dominique
de villepin et nicolas sarkozy côte à
côte
c'est une déesse des tout sauf la
division au fond c'est un bel hommage à
jean pierre raffarin
vous pensez que c'est un problème que
dominique de villepin n'a jamais été élu
écoutez vous savez un homme politique il
est
d'abord au service de son pays raymond
barre qui l'avait jamais été
quand il est devenu premier ministre
était georges pompidou qui est devenu je
me sens bien vite et cherchait lui
président de la république qui n'avait
jamais été
il était élu après donc c'est pas un
critère absolument la de compétences une
qualité non c'est sarkozy qui dit ça se
sait ce qu'on dit que sarkozy dit ah non
je l' ai vu le dire vous l'avez venir à
la télévision dit que sarkozy l'a dit il
est dit que c'était dominique de
villepin non il n'y a pas d'excès
dominique de villepin mais il a dit que
c'est mieux d'être élu quand on est
premier ministre
non j'ai pas dit ça avant ready quoi il
a dit jeudi que rend des hommages à
telus ouais par les électeurs et qui
savaient le prix d'un combat électoral
alors on en arrive maintenant à des
choses plus sérieuses à la doctrine
parce que souvent on reproche à jacques
chirac de pas avoir de doctrine
alors aujourd'hui en termes de doctrine
justement le chômage villepin c'est le
traitement disons sociale ils ont du
chômage sarkozy c'est le traitement
libéral du chemin de fer sarkozy pense
qu'il faut que l'économie marche bien et
mieux l'économie marchera moins il y
aura de chômage villepin lui va nous
refaire les emplois-jeunes quoi en gros
pourquoi vous dites ça c'est parce que
c'est ce que j'ai compris je ne crois
pas dans le domaine économique comme
dans le domaine social
on n'est pas sur un plateau télé il ya
un stop au tel y'a pas un modèle et pas
un autre
je pense que
c'est en permanence l'idée qu'il faut à
la fois balancé entre l'initiative faire
en sorte que la machine ne se grippe pas
ne se ne se bloque pas et puis la
solidarité nécessaire pour les plus de
magie alors dominique de villepin il
incarne sa malle incarne ce côté de
prudence de faire attention à ne pas
mettre en cause la solidarité avec les
plus fragiles
ce que certains ont appelé le modèle
français nicolas sarkozy dit de son côté
est ce que c'est le modèle français que
les 35 heures
le chômage de masse que 10 ministres des
finances en disant que
tout ce qui tout ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la machine ne fonctionne
pas comme elle devrait fonctionner ouais
et donc on a besoin à la fois d'appuyer
sur l'accélérateur mais en même temps de
contrôler la voiture
l'immobilisme hyperactif est ce que vous
croyez pas que faute d'avoir une
doctrine claire on a choisi deux mecs
quand une chacun et elles sont
antinomiques et que cela ne peut pas
marcher parce qu'ils vont tirer chacun
dans un sens on fait raison je crois que
le fait de se ré l'avenir qu'on veut
ressusciter les idéologies c'est
contraire à ce que les gens pensent
aujourd'hui les idéologies en isme c'est
fini le libéralisme pur contre le
marxisme le communisme c'est fini les
gens ont dit que c'était fini et je
crois qu'il faut être pragmatique
aujourd'hui audit lancé le joli à deux
idéologies celle de villepin celle de
sarkozy qui on l'espère vont cohabiter
finalement il y à un pragmatisme il ya
une complémentarité et puis assez des
arbitrages à faire sur les grandes
pistes par exemple on parlait tout à
l'heure de l'amérique
ouais c'est vrai que sarkozy il est
plutôt attentistes et le président en
titre aux américains voilà et fil passé
la france d'abord alors et qui est en
charge de la politique internationale le
président de la république
présent lui qui sait trancher quand il
faut trancher dans la guerre d'irak
il a tranché il a pris il a pas même
partie des états unis ouais mais sur le
plan économique très souvent et bien il
est en phase avec ce qui se passe en
amérique
voilà c'est tout et c'est le présent lui
qui conduit la politique internationale
c'est ce qu'on va faire là on va faire
une interview
si j'étais le gouvernement alors
dominique si vous étiez le gouvernement
aux courriers quoi pour que les français
retrouvent confiance dans la politique
je leur dirai que il ya une phrase de
talleyrand qui était terrible qui disait
quand on s'engage en politique on croit
qu'on va résoudre les problèmes et quand
on fréquente les allées du pouvoir ben
on s'aperçoit que il s'agit pas de les
résoudre les faire durer
eh bien il faut se battre contre ça et
pour ce il faut s'engager en politique
il faut croire à la politique parce que
la vérité de la politique c'est de
résoudre les problèmes des gens
donc il ya une notion de temps il ya une
notion de temps donc les 100 jours de
villepin ça veut dire quelque chose
oui c'est pas assez c'est pas assez oui
parce qu'en plus elle était donc il se
passe pas grand chose l'été nous feriez
croix pour que les français croient en
l'europe encore plus simplement je leur
dirais que quand on est quand on est
tout seul on est plus fragile
et quand on est à 24 25
on est plus fort l'europe c'est que la
valeur de la somme elle est supérieure à
la somme de nos valeurs indique
d'ailleurs je le dis à tout le monde le
dimanche pensez à vos tests importants
mais un deuxième tour vous feriez quoi
pour faire croire aux français que vous
les écoutez si vous étiez le
gouvernement je les écouterai feriez
quoi pour donner de l'espoir aux rmistes
je redirai que on peut travailler plus
pour gagner plus c'est ce qu'a fait jean
pierre raffarin sur les 35 heures il ait
le courage de le faire
et puis surtout que quand on met le pied
sur une marche il faut essayer de mettre
le pied sur la marche supérieure à 16
ans parfois c'est difficile et je vais
vous dire je m'arrête à la première
marche
vous n'y avez oui c'est pour ça qu'il
est toujours être au service
les jeunes disent être des leurs en
avant ce soir
pourquoi tu n'as ni pas une émission
parce qu'on m'arrête à la première
l'argent quel con j'ai eu un déclic ce
soir je vais le produire les pour
relancer la consommation soyez quoi ils
mangeraient comme 4 je ferai ça qu'a
fait jean pierre raffarin je continuerai
à baisser les taxes les charges les
impôts 1 les impôts ont baissé 13
milliards pas personnes 13 milliards
d'euros en 3e au collège personne le
sait saint florent pagny me l'aurait dit
je comprends pourquoi deux minutes pour
réduire le déficit budgétaire de la
france 1000 milliards bien ce qu'a fait
jean pierre raffarin déjà puisque chaque
année il a progressé en mai depuis trois
ans jean pierre jolivet marie avec un
pote
moi je joue bien je tente un truc c'est
quoi ta couleur préférée comme jean
pierre raffin 1000 milliards dans
comment on fait pour rembourser la
aujourd'hui sur ce que produit la france
55 % des dépenses sont des dépenses
publiques 45 % les dépenses de chacun
d'entre nous c'est à dire les dépenses
des privés des ménages et les dépenses
des entreprises après impôts donc c'est
clair qu'il faut rééquilibrer sa est la
seule façon c'est de faire maigrir un
peu l'état c'est à dire que l'auberge
afin qu'ils obligent à la fin il l'a
fait en janvier raffarin il a fait en
sorte que l'on réduise progressivement
les folies par un certain nombre de
fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas de faire en
place et pour combler le trou de la sécu
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
je crois qu'il ya une réforme qui était
mise en place et qu'il faut qu'il faut
accompagner on aurait pu pour réduire le
trou de la sécurité sociale augmenter ce
qu'on appelle la csg c'est à dire un peu
plus un pot à n'y a pas assez d'argent
bas on en prend un but à chacun et comme
son équipe le trou là on a dit faut
aussi se responsabiliser un peu sur une
consultation vous payer un euro chacun
et puis il faut faire attention pas voir
des médecins à tout bout de champ les
médicaments par exemple il vaut mieux
acheter ce rappel des médicaments
génériques et des produits j'ai commencé
à marcher d'heure et ça commence à
marcher blanche d un pharmacien
j'entends quelqu'un on va faire un nom
mais j'ai un remplacement
car qui demandaient du moral et lui mais
je vous donne pas ça mais c'est pareil
c'est le générique et ça coûte 5 euros 2
- 1
voilà c'est des mesures pratiques ça
marche ça et ça commence il a commencé à
baisser trop facile millions d'euros
d'économies dommage que tous le brésil
s'en aille à ce moment-là ce clip et des
affaires étrangères fori quoi pour que
les pauvres soient moins pauvres c'est
plus en plus pauvres les pauvres
d'abord d'abord il ya un vrai il ya un
vrai problème c'est l'euro c'est clair
c'est que les gens ont ce sentiment là
ce que les gens ont le sentiment que
l'euro les a appauvri c'est c'est un peu
vrai parce que c'est vrai hier quand
vous disiez ça coûte 100 francs
c'était cher aujourd'hui 15 euros on a
l'impression que c'est pas cher dans la
rue c'est canteloup me boutin et les
salades dans la rue toi aussi
je crois qu'il faut faire ce qu'a fait
jean pierre raffarin augmenter le smic
comme il ne l'a jamais été depuis 20 ans
de 13 % en trois ans c'est à dire
l'équivalent d'un treizième mois
ça n'avait pas été fait depuis vingt ans
mais ses jambières à part un formidable
mais maintenant quoi il n'est pas prévu
je regrette qu'il soit parti mais kerry
est intervenu ce qu'il a dit je regrette
qu'il soit parti maintenait qu' moi je
pensais je pensais qu'on dirait cette
phrase là dans six mois d'un mois d'un
an jusqu'à un peu dommage si vous étiez
chargé de ça comme et que c'est ce soir
quoi il ya finalement on apprendre tout
ce qu'il appelait donc vous pensez pas
qu'il ya un déficit en fait j'aurais dû
venir chez thierry ardisson plutôt oui
mais vous avez interdit aux ministres de
vannes hier et ça c'est pas une je vous
le dis et c'est comme ça comment l'idée
de dire au ministre n'allait pas dans
les tops sourire vous envoyer dans les
émissions politiques ne font pas
d'audience g et vous le savez parce que
je suis un garçon loyal
oui et donc il y avait eu une une un
principe qui était celui de la
présidence de la république qui consiste
à dire que les ministres faisaient leur
boulot dans les émissions qui était
destiné à permettre les regarde je suis
devenu avec vous quand je raconte dans
ce livre
alors qu'en 1982 coluche arrive sur le
plateau de michel drucker en plein
contrôle des changes se souvenait on
avait interdit d'emporter une carte
bancaire à l'étranger n'est pas le droit
d'emporter sa carte de crédit
ce gouvernement mauroy un coluche il
arrive sur le plateau de drucker avec
une vache
derrière lui c'est un truc qui redit qu
est ce qui se passe je pars en vacances
en espagne
et comme j'ai pas le droit d'en porter
ma carte de crédit j'emporte de quoi
bouffer et en fait il a fait beaucoup
plus que tous les discours d'hommes
politiques parce que dans une émission
de divertissement de variétés et où il a
touché le coeur des gens donc je suis
d'accord avec vous thierry ardisson non
il ya deux trucs à parfaire la soirée
lat il ya des trucs que j'ai pas compris
c'est un pourquoi les ministres en
exercice n'avait pas le droit de venir
ici par exemple où il aurait pu
s'expliquer devant des gens jeunes
dynamique et pas seulement les gens qui
regardent les émissions politiques à la
télévision et la deuxième chose c'est
que pendant les deux mois qui ont
précédé le référendum sur l'europe
les hommes politiques ont été interdits
ici on n'a pas le droit d'en parler
comme si ridicule franchement c'est à ce
moment là qu'il fallait en parler car ça
vient quand on n'a pas parlé c'est trop
nord je suis un homme de télévision
aussi et je suis d'accord avec thierry
ardisson à laurent baffie sur ce sujet
quand matignon j'ai publié cette norme
messieurs
[Musique]
dominique mercy avoir été avec nos
habitations
[Musique]
j'accueille jean michel jarre
bonsoir jean michel jarre bonsoir
questionne pas il fait des concerts avec
des millions de gens donc ça
n'impressionne pas du tout ça va
jean-michel ça va très bien toujours
avec anne parillaud toujours qu'il va
nous rejoindre dans un instant sa fille
marche ou non vous n'avez pas les
cheveux plus longs que la dernière fois
que vous êtes venu jean michel c'est
possible comment vous faites pour des
cheveux comme ça voulait laver avec cool
it esclave après le shampooing tu mets
un démêlant jamais c'est vrai mais
qu'est ce qui leur donne cette brillante
même si celle où ses looks c'est mon nom
il ya des produits et c'est pas grave
j'ai introduit sociaux quand il soit le
matin comme ça c'est tout jean-michel
dont vous êtes ici pour notre temps et
les racines
jean michel vous êtes ici pour notre
temps tu te laves tous les condamnent
tous les jours jones m ce même toutes
les semaines
oui merci jean michel jarre en voix
jean michel vous êtes ici pour de sortir
en dvd donc comment bien se coiffer
relier le sont ici pas de sortir en dvd
sous le nom de jazz in china du concert
qu'il donnait à pékin dans la cité
interdite et sur la place tiananmen le
10 octobre 2004 alors il ya le dvd 1 que
l'on a cité interdite le dvd 2 qui est
sur la place tiananmen
et entre les deux le chemin le plus
court pour passer d'un endroit à l'autre
c'est une une allée centrale au milieu
de la cité interdite
les deux dernières personnes qui avaient
emprunté ce passage c'est le dernier
empereur est dingue shopping donc c'est
aussi bien renseignés voilà donc vous
êtes passés là hein mais pas en voiture
je crois en cette carte exacte alors
concert énorme deux cent soixante
musiciens c'est ce caméra haute
définition et le label thx lorsque j'ai
appris en fait en regardant vos dvd ans
en lisant la brochure c'est que thx et
passait pas un format en fait c'est un
label de son label de qualité
ah oui c'est ça c'est taxer le sait les
studios de george lucas c'est une marque
bio croise ce ce label à l'époque du
premier star wars pour essayer justement
d'avoir une un son et une image qui soit
le meilleur possible effectivement c'est
la première fois que s'est attribué un
dvd et musicale alors on va regarder à
quoi ça ressemble vous regardez votre
caméra à l'embouchure des cheveux comme
ça magnéto thierry magnéto serge magnéto
serge
[Musique]
e
voilà jean michel jarre est une shana
alors
j'ai fait d'élever on trouve également
liberté d'expression donc c'est vous et
souhaite jeunes qui est le numéro un du
rock chinois
celui qui en 1989 au moment du mouvement
étudiant avait chanté sur la place
tiananmen avec un bandeau rouge sur les
yeux alors dans le dvd on le voit
répéter la chanson de piaf la foule
pendant dans un studio et ensuite on
vous voit lui expliquer que vous n'êtes
pas sûr de pouvoir le faire monter sur
scène effectivement il ya eu un veto des
autorités chinoises
mais mais ça c'est dit nulle part comme
la langue dans le dvd quand quand on m'a
proposé ce de faire l'ouverture de la
france en chine au coeur de pékin avant
d'accepter
j'ai rencontré quand même un certain
nombre d'amis écrivains des musiciens ou
artistes ou intellectuels chinois pour
savoir si c'était finalement bien par
rapport à la vision qu'ont à nous de la
chine et pas seulement la vision qu'on a
mais c'est la réalité c'est à dire qu'un
pays qui n'est quand même pas
complètement raccord et politiquement
correct au plan de droits de l'homme
savoir c'était une bonne idée de faire
et j'ai été étonné de voir quelle 100%
des des artistes chinois ont dit il faut
il faut absolument que tu le fasses
d'abord bon on ne connaît en chine
ensuite ce n'est pas un chinois qui va
le faire et pour nous c'est une
opportunité de pouvoir reprendre la main
sur le plan culturel sur le plan
intellectuel au sein de la capitale et
donc la responsabilité moi qu'est la
condition je me suis mise à moi même
c'était d'intégrer et de vraiment de
d'essayer de d'impliquer les les
musiciens dissidents les peintres les
vidéastes au maximum dans ce concert pas
sous forme de festival est vraiment d
appliquer dans le projet et ça ça a été
finalement assez réussi on a
effectivement négocié pied à pied
jusqu'au bout et que sur le sont les
trois musiciens effectivement qui était
avec moi sur scène qu'ils étaient tous
les trois très impliquée dans les
évènements 89 un seul n'a pas pu n'a pas
pu être là et ils nous ont expliqué
d'ailleurs mais finalement je les gère
reconnue c'est que il ya une différence
pour aller faire des concerts comme ça
comme ça et puis et puis de faire un
concert dans un cadre extrêmement
formelle avec devant les membres du
gouvernement qui seront pris à la
télévision en direct en train de nous
dire c'est donc c'était donc finalement
on a on est tombé d'accord que
illustrations de dvd qui serait sur la
retransmission internet mais que deux
autres musiciens notamment la fille
qu'on vient de voir jouer qui est qui
était une des grandes chanteuses et
joueuses de deux héros chinois qui a été
la femme du leader étudiant 89 soit là
donc je pense que je pense que c'est
bien aussi de comprendre aussi le fait
que bon bah finalement sur trois il y en
a deux qui étaient là et puis évidemment
bon le fait de dire liberté égalité
fraternité en chinois en direct à la
télévision était finalement un pari
réussi et les objectifs que je m'étais
fixé et qu'on s'était fixés je pensais
peut-être parfaitement réussi et je
crois que ça ça pose la question de
savoir est ce qu'il faut aller dans un
pays comme la chine
est ce qu'il faut aller s'exprimer ce
qu'il faut les jouer ce qu'il faut aller
montrer ses films est ce qu'il faut
aller
la réponse à mon avis est évidemment oui
puisque vous êtes jallet mais reporter
sans frontières étaient opposés à ça et
vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs oui et je
trouve que c'est une erreur
je pense que il faut arrêter d'avoir ces
espèces de d'arrogant souvent au boycott
mouche qui fait que au bout du compte
en ce qui concerne les chinois les
chinois comme se fiche un peu de
l'opinion de la france et je crois que
c'est pas une solution je crois qu'il
faut il faut être astucieux il faut
venir à l'intérieur du bâtiment
d'ailleurs vous y aller et puis ils ont
noyé un système c'est ce qui est à
signaler quand même c'est que c'est la
première fois que la télévision chinoise
a retransmis un concert en direct sans
coupure c'est que j'aurais très bien pu
me couper aussi quand quand j'ai fait
liberté et de fraternité un chinois sur
la place tiananmen c'est vrai qu'ils
auraient tout à fait pu lui le coupé ils
n'ont pas fait alors isabelle adjani bon
on va pas revenir là dessus c'est plein
de votre attitude jean-michel voilà on a
déjà parlé il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui
récemment ici c'est plein de votre
attitude c'est jean pierre raffarin
non ça m'a fait du bien il y en a pour à
chaque fois un point et si on essayait
classé le plus souvent possible jean
pierre raffarin c'est ça c'est le but du
jeu tu marques un point chacun il fait
des grandes frédéric on le faire
habilement il ya quelqu'un d'autre qui
récemment ici c'est plein de votre
attitude c'est patrick juvet qui s'est
plaint que vous l'avez laissé tombé en
mer d'après une histoire d'amour et lima
laisser tomber et ses malheurs
apparemment viennent de là s'il est dans
cet état la patrie que j'avais
aujourd'hui je savais pas moi c'est
parce que vous avez vous avez abandonné
je suis très bas je suis très troublé
quand une valise à la consigne la langue
non cotées du téléphone qu'est ce qui
s'est passé et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
sérieusement vous étiez très proche à un
moment et puisque trois chez soi qu'elle
soit que ce soit patrick juvet ou
christophe ou d'autres effectivement
j'ai travaillé avec moi travailler
ensemble les deux albums on est on a
toujours été très bons amis évidemment
il y mettait une dimension de redux la
directive voire amoureuse que vous ne
mettiez au ram s'extérioriser plus ça
aurait peut-être changé mon destin pour
l'heure en tout cas ça n'a pas été le
cas
mais comme un peu un bourreau des coeurs
quand même un bon je sais pas si avons
tiré qu'à l'école jeudi déjà des
maîtresses bien il est toujours avec
anne parillaud déçoit à voir quel type
de mec vous êtes jean michel jarre en
faire une interview vérif
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez déjà appliqué une
fille à un copain piqué peut-être pas ce
qui a pu y a pu y avoir une passation de
pouvoir
jean pierre raffarin
alors qu'est ce qu'on a à faire on ne va
pas tout c'est noté on va noter ceux qui
tombent vraiment je suis là il tombe
jusqu'à la passation de pouvoir jean
pierre raffarin bois volant est ce que
j'ai déjà trompé votre copine alors
qu'elle était enceinte
2 jean pierre raffarin n'ont jamais
tenté
non ça me rassure t il marche pourquoi
il a jamais embauché personne
jean-pierre à sa femme mais j'ai envie
de copines enceintes
ouais donc je n'ai pas pu voilà donc
d'accord vous ai déjà proposé le mariage
et une fille en sachant que vous le
feriez pas non vous avez déjà révélé que
les seins d'une fille était faux
révélé à qui ad'autres j'ai bien une
idée mais ça va pas lui plaire
je tente même pu déjà barré de chez une
fille à morgane se réveille
jamie on dit la vérité at it et jamy
avant qu'elle se réveille bon non je
crois pas non non c'est des gestes jean
pierre raffarin
celui-là on pourrait en trouver
yes de poids bien voilà il est déjà
rappelé une ex juge pour vérifier
qu'elle voulait encore couché avec vous
mais non pas aux normes baba il le fait
mais non pas du tout comme ça moi
pouvoir est ou non plus et un sens
finalement un check-in vip ans et non
six nations
est-ce que tu as menti dans cette
interview pas du tout tu as toujours une
positive attitude quand même jean michel
jarre
c'est l'art de la joute
[Musique]
et
à millau
c'est la première fois que vous êtes
réunis sur un plateau de télévision non
c'est le hasard il faut plus c'est le
hasard sur soi que tournez manège en
somme vous devez venir il ya trois
semaines
ouais payer le mariage tout ça les
occuper voilà un qui en sort un film
donc ces voix là bas c'est tombé comme
ça c'est tombé comme ça vous n'allez pas
faire le début de l'émission et l'arrêt
donc oui on a fait ça avec laurent gerra
et mathilde seigner pas évident de se
séparer en même temps mais j'étais pas
très préféré comme il s'appelle anne
jarre ou anne parillaud anne parillaud
jarre et anne parillaud jarre
j'ai entendu l'interview vérif la juste
avant il est formidable c'est il a aucun
défaut et jean-michel 25 web il a jamais
fait un coup tordu et une gonzesse
j'en ai entendu que la moitié 1 parce
qu'entre temps m'a fait descendre ne
vous écoute pas tout ce que je dis non
mais il est formidable c'est ta chance
mail de florent pagny est ce que vous
êtes mariés pour les impôts
ouais je sais même pas ce que ça change
à ce niveau là lui oui les amis pardon
jean michel vous qui êtes habitué à
rassembler des millions de gens dits
'tier pas déçus qui est que 350
personnes à votre mariage
yves et moi il ya des maïs était intime
alors restée intime
il ya un petit comité un oui mais
beaucoup moins l'année dernière il avait
l'algérie a déclaré dans la presse que
vous lui aviez promis le mariage avant
de la tromper avec anne vous avez
regretté
vous l'avez dit ici d'ailleurs cet
étalage de votre vie privée dans la
presse people
un an plus tard vous épousez anne et
vous fait la couverture de paris match
est-ce qu'il ya pas un petit souci ben
c'est pas un truc perso le mariage c'est
pas ça je pense que effectivement à
partir du moment où on aider des gens
public on est exposé à être poursuivis
parce que ce qu'on a ce qu'on a beaucoup
vécu depuis depuis un an d'un an et demi
et que la rétention à tout prix de ce
sens n'est pas n'est pas non plus une
solution
donc au bout du bout du compte je pense
que s'exposer c'est aussi se protéger il
ya beaucoup réfléchir oui c'est simple
quand c'est isabelle adjani qui raconte
ses malheurs dans match vous trouvez que
c'est une atteinte à la vie privée
on fait donc ça n'a rien à voir avec ça
non la différence c'est de mettre en
cause des gens en racontant des choses
qui ne sont pas vraies et en mettant en
cause en particulier des gens qui n'ont
rien à voir avec les protagonistes
c'est à dire ma famille mes enfants
et c'est avec qui aujourd'hui isabelle
adjani oui tu vas pas me croire
tu sais que tu sais ouais
est-ce que je vous pose une question que
je les ai vu l'article dans match je me
demande si vous avez vérifié letizi on
vous a donné à les lire avant
publication
il ya écrit ils ressemblent à des gosses
indécrottable gallopin qui nous font
rêver d'éternelle jeunesse c'est beau à
l'écrit bien way we écrit très bien
alors vous avez déclaré dans l paris
lorsque je les ai vus en parlant de jean
michel
j'ai su que c'était lui ben oui j'ai
rien à un jeu tiens c'est vrai c'était
quand votre première rencontre c'était
l'année dernière début 2004 au milieu de
mille quatre vingt dans le premier
semestre 2004 vous êtes rencontrés
comment j'ai rencontré chez des amis
communs qu'elle a mis ça on va justement
le garder pour nous et tout de suite
vous avez senti que c'était jean-michel
quoi vous vous connaissiez quand même il
est connu jean michel pouré besoins
attendus ce jour là non mais je crois
que bon on peut on peut on peut voir les
choses comme ça mais effectivement
toutes les toutes les rencontres sont
des rencontres qui au fond
ce sont toujours les mêmes jusqu'à ce
qu' il y en ait une qui soit
fondamentalement différent mais j'avais
le même coup de foudre vaut pour c'est
pas un coup de pouce est une évidence
donc ce n'est pas un coup de foudre
c'est d'une certaine manière le
contraire d'un coup de foudre le contrat
de quelque chose qui se consume au
contraire vous savez quoi
voilà ça c'est ça c'est le mot on va on
va dire que c'est le mot reconnaissance
exactement vous vous arrêtez votre
troisième mariage quelle erreur elle a
évité cette fois pas de lutter déjà non
non non je vais continuer je pense que
je pense que quand on je pense que quand
on quand on se marie à l'église c'est
une dimension totalement différente et
que moi j'ai pas du tout l'impression de
vivre le mariage comme un comme un
carcan et en une comme une obligation au
contraire comme une libération et si on
parle de la fidélité
je pense que la fidélité c'est plutôt
c'est plutôt une forme de liberté quand
quand on rencontre quelqu'un avec qui on
se sent finalement totalement en phase
qui n'est pas nécessairement le ce qui
n'a pas été nécessairement le cas avant
du tout lorsque vous êtes venus ici à
trois ans presque jour pour jour vous
avez dit j'adore être soumise regarde un
pygmalion quelqu'un qui me construit en
fait
et vous pensez qu'avec jean michel
faisait trouvé ce pygmalion qui va vous
construire non je pense que justement
c'est très différent et c'est pour ça
que moi ce que j'ai senti c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai jamais senti
auparavant et et justement j'ai souvent
j'ai pu me trompe
enfin je renie rien et je ne regrette
rien parce qu'effectivement tout ça ça a
été une construction important pour moi
mais le besoin de pygmalion c'est aussi
parfois une façon dévié de ne pas savoir
ce qu'on cherche de ne pas savoir ce qui
vous manque et de trouver à travers le
puma lionisme un semblant d'équilibré
d'harmonie
justement c'est quelque chose qui
n'existe pas et jean-michel et c'est
donc pour moi essentiel parce qu'on part
sur une sur une base de partage et non
pas sur base de solutions une relation
c'est évidemment lié à une notion d'
équilibre donc je pense qu'elle a autant
à m'apprendre que j'ai à lui apprendre
jusque là la veille des pygmalion oui
c'est pas nul a dit alors ma vie aussi
je me vois pas belle je me vis pas
belges et des troubles avec mon image ça
va mieux là oui mais je vous avais dit
aussi qui à l'époque il fallait que que
saviez ça provenait safran venait de
l'enfance évidemment comme toutes les
grandes séquelles qui perdure en tant
qu'adulte et que finalement le monde
d'amour que j'ai pu ressentir à tord ou
à raison la seule façon effectivement de
le combler c'est d'en recevoir et de
savoir le prendre
le vivre le reconnaître et c'est vrai
que c'est quelque chose qui est
notamment en train d'évoluer m'aviez dit
j'aurai finalement plus aimé être une
femme au foyer élever des enfants avoir
un mari qui rentrent le soir
non je vais tout faire maintenant j'ai
envie de tout faire mais alors vous
disiez à l'époque que j'arrive pas à
être heureuse j'ai pas les éléments
chimiques qu'il faut aujourd'hui ça va
aujourd'hui ça paraît totalement mais
tout va tout va tout va mais parce qu'en
fait je pense que c'est vrai pour tout
le monde c'est pour moi en fait je suis
quelqu'un d'assez simple cirque à partir
de monde vous avez l'essentiel et à
partir du moment où effectivement il ya
la rencontre avec l'autre il ya
énormément de choses qui s'élimine il ya
énormément de choses des problématiques
qui s'évanouissent bien évidemment
puisque d'ascq où vous vous vivez à
travers un regard qui exonère totalement
le sujet de la fidélité dans le couple
disiez que vous n'y croyez pas non c'est
vrai mais j'ai dit beaucoup beaucoup de
choses jusqu'à aujourd'hui vous y croyez
en fait en fait toutes les déclarations
que j'ai pu faire et donc toutes celles
que vous me demandez c'est une réponse à
la raison pour laquelle je me suis marié
en fait plus réponse ah non pas du tout
pour plus répond ça pour parce que mes
réponses en plus du tout la même et sont
valables surtout je renie rien du tout
de tout ce que j'ai pu dire est que
toutes les théories que j'avais pu
échafauder gelé sont totalement encore
légitime à mes yeux mais il y avait
juste un bémol que je ne connaissais pas
qui est effectivement si vous rencontrez
la personne qui est fabriqué pour vous
auquel cas il ya beaucoup de choses
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure qui vont
disparaître mais donc effectivement il
ya beaucoup de problèmes de régler
beaucoup de choses et donc la fidélité
c'est quelque chose qui ne se pose plus
à partir du monde quel est le besoin
pour un individu d'aller chez quand on
est infidèle c'est parce qu enfin bon je
vais parler pour moi dans ma définition
d'infidélité c'était parce que
vraisemblablement j'allais chercher un
petit morceau d'une personne dans
plusieurs et qu'à partir du moment où
j'ai le tout je vais pas régresser et
repartir chercher des petits morceaux
vous me disiez aussi je maurice était
meilleure à plusieurs vous me disiez il
faut tout essayer meilleur avec une
femme il faut tout essayer bon là
maintenant j'imagine que aujourd'hui
tout ça c'est s'est passé c'est obsolète
ces cas du qs et voilà c'est jean-michel
maintenant vous poser même pu toutes ces
questions j'oserais même de vous les
posez d'ailleurs moi pouvoir mariage
réussi unis pour le meilleur et pour le
pire
le pire c'est quoi avec jean-michel
alors à part la coiffure
moi j'aime beaucoup ça passionnant là
ils sont un peu longs non vous êtes
beaucoup disputés depuis le 14 mai non
non je vais faire une une interview
briseur de ménage est ce que vous êtes
toujours amoureuse de jean michel
oui est-ce qu'il vous regarde toujours
avec la même fougue crise dites moi il
fait le ménage à la maison jean michel
non mais moi non plus hein et la cuisine
non mais manon prix c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous emmenez week-end
c'était aussi des eaux la dernière fois
que vous avez offert des fleurs
voilà je n'aime pas beaucoup les fleurs
et lui non plus il vous ouvre la
portière de la voiture
oui ils vous accompagnez les reports
quand vous partez je ne sais pas encore
parti de là vous n'avez pas vous séparer
en fait c'est pas s'il viendra vous
chercher quand vous reviendrez donc il
vous fait des petits déjeuners au lycée
déjeuner au lit
j'aime pas ça les regarde les filles
dans la rue non
il est une photo de vous dans son
portefeuille ça sent fort salle il
laisse des messages d'amour sur le
miroir de la salle de bain du rouge à
lèvres je t'aime jamie lépine motors
portable c'est quoi qui vous énerve le
plus chez lui jan
tu l'a droguée c'est pas possible est-ce
qu'on laisse traîner ses chaussettes
on cherche la faille il désordonnée des
miettes dans le lit est de mieux en
mieux mais je suis très fournis aussi
pour moi on se ressemble beaucoup et ça
me dérangera pas vous l'avez déjà chopé
un travail peu importe au nom desquels
vous avez tourné rajotte
et
m
voilà alors jean-michel vous allez nous
laisser seuls avec anne parillaud
oui mais avant je ris qu'on parle de la
pologne parce qu après la chine c'est la
pologne c'est lech walesa qui vous a
demandé d'aller faire un concert à
gdansk pour solidarnosc et sa wii pour
le 25ème anniversaire de solidarnosc
j'ai fait un concert fin août
effectivement je vais rencontrer les
balises à dans deux semaines pour ce qui
en fait devient quelque chose de tout à
fait extraordinaire sur un plan sur le
plan polonais puisque c'est la mort du
pape
et puis avec le nom du verre du
référendum c'est vrai que je pense qu'il
faut pas oublier aussi qu'il ya des pays
qui sont la porte de l'europe et qui
sont autant d'idées qui sont content d'y
être
et donc c'est bien d'aller rassurer
aussi oui très bien c'est sur ces
aberrations
vous êtes ici pour un film qui s'appelle
deadline c'est un film de ludi boeken et
michael bernard avec stephen moyer qui
sort le 8 juin 2005 alors le pitch c'est
un jeune reporter un peu arrivistes qui
débarque à beyrouth en 1983 au moment où
des camions suicide font sauter des
bases américaines et des bases
françaises le fameux l'immeuble du
drakkar et y rencontre une mystérieuse
photographe joué par vous et il comprend
à ce moment là qu'il faut choisir entre
la frime des faux scoop et la vérité du
journalisme oui c'est un film sur les
manier la manipulation médiatique alors
en faisant ses films vous avez pensé que
si vous aviez 20 ans leur passion vous
aurez donné envie de partir vous aussi
mais en même temps vous avez découvert
que finalement derrière ses conceptions
un petit peu utopiste il y avait quand
même un désir de fuite
il y avait un désespoir il y avait un
désir d'émotions fortes et d'adrénaline
que ce n'est pas aussi aussi pure que ça
en même temps c'est ça qui m'a touché
c'est ça qui est beau aussi parce que
c'est toujours inintéressant
les gens extrêmement cadré où les gens
extrêmement enfin qu'avec un une seule
ligne comme ça et que c'est vrai que
c'est pas que des chevaliers c'est pas
que des témoins de la mémoire ou de
l'histoire ça l'est aussi et c'est
important bien évidemment content qu'on
parle de leur profession mais est-ce que
c'en est une autre c'est la question que
je me suis posée parce qu'effectivement
à côté de ça et à côté de l'utopie
originel vouloir témoigner des veillées
des consciences c'est vrai que c'est des
personnes qui finalement vivent
totalement en réalité hors normes qui
sont totalement des cadres et qui ont
besoin de la guerre pour avoir de
l'adrénaline
oui qui sont toxiques au du terrain qui
sont toxiques au dessus du scoop et qui
effectivement est ce que ça révèle pas
une fuite de la réalité pas du réel
parce que le paradoxe en fait aussi
c'est qu'ils sont vraiment dans le réel
mais or la réalité
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble et
regardez votre caméra c'est le diable
rouge et vous allez dire magnéto serge
magnéto serge
en direct
chez trois heures pour faire un méga
reportage dans un pays où je viens
d'arriver
alors quelques mois dec
[Musique]
je
mais
c'est la moindre violence en lui je
pense que je le saurai non
pourquoi nous
parce que je reste allez bonne et douce
le
bientôt payer pour m'avoir intoxiqué a
du culot de même je sais comme ça
c'était tellement avide d'avoir ton
histoire que t'as rien vérifié toi même
si je mens tu n'as la vérité je serais
mort depuis longtemps
merde
tard une photo sépia pourquoi tu m'as
bien sûr l'antenne aux parce que je dis
créée voilà déjà avec ses faibles moyens
yann cariou qui est notre invité ce soir
alors
vous avez reçu pour ce film le prix
d'interprétation du festival de paris et
lors de la remise du prix vous avez
déclaré comme je suis un peu névrotique
merci de me sauver qu'est ce que ça veut
dire j'ai vraiment dit ça oui ça me
choque aujourd'hui de l'entendre en fait
mais si je me dis si aujourd'hui vous
êtes sauvés mais c'est assez bon
maintenant on sait que c'est fait merci
j'ai dit ça j'ai dessau remercions pour
le prix non alors peut-être aussi
c'était parce que les prix moi c'est
quelque chose qui me c'est comme une
crème c'est comme un baume c'est comme
un une pommade ça soigne pas ça guérit
pas mais qu'est-ce que ça soulage donc
j'allais peut-être dit aussi dans ce
cadre des de dire ben e
merci de me sauver dans le sens où quand
on reconnaît six mois j'ai du mal à me
reconnaître si les autres le font à ma
place c'est effectivement quelque chose
que je je remercie c'est bien vu
extrêmement extrêmement primé en france
mais aussi à l'étranger dans énormément
de festival c'est un film important ça
s'appelle deadlines et ça sort le 8 juin
monsieur c'est la bande originale
et dangereuse
[Musique]
je vais vous laisser aller retour et
jean-michel à bientôt à
[Musique]
j'accueille jamiroquai
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir jay kay le leader du groupe
jamiroquai 20 millions d'albums vendus
et quand on écoute on comprend pourquoi
didier
[Applaudissements]
m
ah non
mais
je suis
m
[Musique]
mon cher
free janeiro toi
voilà après presque quatre ans d'absence
jamiroquai sort un nouvel album le 20
juin
il s'appelle dynamite est le premier
single c
c'est bien
sympa
jamiroquai
en effet le saônois
qu'ils s'appellent dynamique alors je
vais pas réussi à joindre aux landaus
mais je suis sûr qu'ils exigent le clip
so please jamiroquai est ce que vous
pouvez regarder votre caméra c'est le
cas leur lumière rouge et vous dites
magnéto serge magnéto serge manière
sèche
bravo
[Musique]
mon adjoint puis le jazz nights choc
qu'ils s'appellent dynamique voilà
jamiroquai you you know jean michel
jarre niono jean michel jarre et absolu
lui évidemment je le connais je oui je
suis un grand fan de jeu du chasseur est
ce que jean-michel pour venir pour
serrer la main de jamiroquai
jean-michel jamais recoins il vient de
dire qu'il était un grand fan de un
grand fan de vous est ce que vous êtes
un grand fan de lui
oui absolument passer c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui est qu'il ya un style
totalement particulier qui je pense
qu'on se retrouve c'est qu'il a une
manière de traiter le son qui est
totalement unique dans dans un 2e
catégorie de musique totalement
différente mais mais c'est avant tout du
son des mères à quoi et c'est pour ça
que depuis le départ moi c'est quelqu'un
qui m'a branché mais immédiatement
indépendamment de son talent de
performeurs et de haut niveau du son
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est
immédiatement cesser décalé par rapport
à tout un genre de musique qui
existaient et qui en a fait une patte
qu'il y en a une patte unique
particulier il te connais d'accord mais
do you know jean pierre raffarin alors
jamiroquai quand on s'interroge sur
cette grâce ce que vous avez dans la
composition musicale et dans
l'interprétation vocale
en fait on trouve la réponse dans votre
biographie votre mère car heynckes s'est
lancé à 14 ans dans une carrière de
chanteuse de jazz
à 17 ans elle était sur la même scène
que les beatles que ronnie scott ou
dizzy gillespie
est-ce que c'est finalement sac c'est
cette jeunesse se baigner dans la
musique qui vous a donné cette grâce lui
absolument effectivement ma mère une
influence très importante sur moi depuis
que j'étais tout gamin
moi j'étais dans le coup lisse et
j'étais souvent avec les musiciens là et
elle s'occupait des musiciens les
enfants d'un musicien ou mais en fait
c'est sûr ça quand elle était sûre celle
là elle avait pu le temps occupé de moi
évidemment y avait des ventes d'écrans
que des grands ténors qui jouent elles
disent avons une passe trois ans c'était
vraiment tous le sont tous à la musique
que j'ai entendu qu'il a bercé mon
enfance et donc ça a été vraiment une
influence numéro un pour moi s'il très
bonne école pour vous effectivement et à
l'âge de 4 ans pendant un show de votre
mère vous entrez sur scène en criant
maman maman maman vous en souvenez de sa
belle parce que c'est très bien avoir
traversé dix danseuses et bon c'est pour
sa tête qu'autre chose j'aime autant
leschi les chaussures l'heure actuelle
parce que j'étais toujours encadré de
fille qui était grande récré grande gens
de grandes chaussures que les grands
chevaux c'est pour ça que j'ai un peu
fétiche question chaussures m'enfin bon
alors à la même époque
votre premier grand émoi musical c'est
shaft par isaac hayes ça a été vraiment
pour vous une révélation
james avait tellement sur moi c'est
incroyable toutes ces infos non mais
c'est vrai c'est super mais vous avez
raison
effectivement mon grand père avait une
table
et puis il y avait un petit tracteur
rouge et moi je suis allé là autour de
ça on arrête ton char c'est évidemment
la première chose à voir aussi que
faisait partie ma mère faisait 1964 à
jouer en club avant qu'il soit vraiment
très connu donc effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui s inscrit dans la
durée tout cette histoire avec la
musique
maintenant il faut que vous me demandiez
ce que vous me disiez ce que j'ai pris
tous les jeux
donc voilà comment s'explique le goût
musical de jamiroquai et son instabilité
aussi et puis alors on découvre quand on
étudie un petit peu votre biographie
pourquoi vous aimez tellement les
voitures c'est parce que votre mère
n'avait pas de véritable pied-à-terre et
vous avez passé une bonne partie de
votre enfance à l'arrière des voitures
ce qui explique votre passion pour les
bolides sans doute vous demandiez à
votre mère d'accélérer quand vous étiez
sur la route avec elle voilà acheteurs
et va pas lui font c'est vrai que
j'adore toujours les sièges arrière des
blessures mais vous voyez ça s'exporte
en fait effectivement c'est vrai que
j'ai grandi sur les autres c'est là que
c'est de là que me vient cet amour quand
les vôtres parce que quand été placées
aux quatre coins du pays à longueur de
temps et bien tout ce qu'il vous reste à
faire passer regarder les bagnoles et
donc les bagnoles années 70 c'était très
différent que plus intéressante qu'elle
ne sont à l'heure actuelle elle avait
une triumph votre mère avait une ce
triomphe 13 60
alors voilà c'est pas facile quand on
est enfant de bouger de faire des études
jamiroquai jay kay a eu une enfance un
peu compliqué il enfance pas facile à
l'époque votre mère travaille beaucoup
parfois vous rentrez chez vous il ya
personne qu'on vous rentrez et vous
n'êtes pas assez grand pour mettre la
clé dans la serrure et vous êtes obligés
d'aller voir les voisins en pleurant
pour qui vous ouvre la porte de chez
vous ce n'était pas drôle tous les jours
j'ai pu être en internat
dès l'âge de 4 ans j'étais jeune gamin
de l'école j'ai été dans cet internat
différents tout simplement parce que ma
mère devait travailler et donc les gens
ont frappé dès le premier jour tout
simplement parce que j'avais parlé à mon
camarade pendant le repas de foire en
fait j'avais pas nous aviez droit de
parler à certaines personnes mais bon
papa lui en l'occurrence et donc c'était
très strictes et donc ils vont ils m'ont
battu et je pense que ça m'a donné
l'indépendance dont je jouais à l'heure
actuelle et il faut bien voir ainsi que
ça a développé en moi cette indépendance
vous savez qu'il faut grandir rapidement
qu'il faut faire ses preuves
voilà alors en parlant d'indépendance à
l'âge de 16 ans vous discutez avec votre
mère vous devenez tagueurs vous allez
vivre dans un squat vous fait des petits
boulots et vous avez même vendu du shit
c'est vrai vous avez vendu du haschich
jay kay a à manger on dit du chiffre
mais vous je pourrais d'ailleurs bien
fut même toujours non ce serait sympa
il ya des fois où il ya des moments où
si vous voulez faire de la musique et
bien à ce moment là vous allez faire
tous les efforts il faut pour y arriver
est effectivement là je me suis rendu
compte qu'il fallait que je fasse un
certain nombre d'efforts avec le fasse
un certain nombre de choses que je
récupère l'argent nécessaire pour cause
pour m'acheter le matériel angers le
besoin pour me lancer
et puis ensuite j'ai pu sortir de tout
ça et puis moi je savais ce que je
voulais faire ça c'était j'avais quelque
chose d'eux elle fixe est là dessus sur
la musique c'était ce que je voulais
c'était vraiment fait du hasch libanais
de stuc vous faites ça fait plein de
petits boulots pour essayer d'accumuler
de l'argent vous n'êtes pas très heureux
à cette époque là et un jour vous vous
dites si tu veux faire la musique fait
de la musique ne fait plus que de la
musique
même si tu dois mourir de faim à ce
moment là vous retournez chez votre mère
vous vous enfermez pendant six semaines
dans la salle de bains transformé en
studio et là vous créez en très peu de
temps en fait le concept jamiroquai et
le logo le logo avec les buffalos
manière que vous inventez ça très
rapidement finalement j'ai voulu sortir
de tous les problèmes que je traversais
donc je rentrais chez moi j'étais dans
ma chambre je me suis assis là je me
suis dit bon alors à temps qu'est ce que
je vais faire maintenant il faut que je
fasse quelque chose que je présente
quelque chose à l'entreprise ses disques
produits finis donc ce que je trouvais
matignon pour le groupe donc la première
chose que j'ai faite c'est que j'ai
essayé de les signer ce type la bande
dessinée parce que je me suis dit que
c'était un symbole que les gens les
reconnaît facilement et je me suis dit
pas si le voit régulièrement ils vont le
reconnaître même s'il n'ya pas de nom et
c'est le cas voilà alors le premier
producteur qui a reçu votre cassette au
départ il a cru que c'était une diva
noir en écoutant votre voix il pouvait
pas imaginer une seconde que c'était un
jeune anglais c'est une voie que vous
avez hérité de votre mère oui absolument
c'est une vérité
en fait j'ai fait une interview radio à
londres et le type m'a dit c'est qui
cette femme noire qu'on entend la main
les jib annoncé voilà
et là c'est le succès un succès
considérable et rapide vous donnez une
star mondiale vous donnez milliardaire
et vous devenez aussi cocaïnomane
vingtaine d'années ils ne pourront pas
fortement grandi à l'époque c'était
années rock'n'roll mais les filles
évident qu'à canal de la vodka et part
ça il ya eu des débordements donc je
pense que l'idée c'était pas trop
d'aller plus loin c'était ces époques
pour arriver à monter sur scène c'était
simplement pour les inventeurs de la
scène et on atterrit c'est parce qu'une
fois que vous avez fini votre spectacle
il fallait atterrir et l'atterrissage
parfois été un peu difficile donc on
tomber là-dedans facilement enfin bon
c'est fini maintenant je suis toujours
là je me rends compte
j'ai été je suis propre depuis cinq mois
oui c'est terminé s'est terminée
aujourd'hui grâce à un ami à vous qui
s'appelle olic est un ami de longue date
et un jour vous rencontrez ce au lit
vous dit qu'il a des problèmes d'argent
vous lui dites que vous avez des
problèmes de drogue et voulait dit je
vais te payer pour tu me surveille et
effectivement depuis le 1er janvier 2004
vous n'avez pas pris de drogue vous avez
l'air très bien là quelqu'un qui a
essayé de me vendre je lui dis non à
jeudi à orly à l'époque sénateur sur
place et je l'avais beaucoup aidé
voyager pendant sa ville à dire pendant
les tours en amérique en amérique du sud
un peu partout et donc il était dans le
creux de la vague et donc je dis je dis
allez je l'étais à redevenir heureux
donc je dis allez on est potes
j'ai besoin que tu m'aides à ton tour et
donc combien tu allais je lui fis part
de ton salaire tu vas bosser pendant 24
heures sur 24 on va se lever le matin va
le courir on va faire ceci à travers on
va raser toutes les pages des endroits
où on peut sortir et c'est donc et si
j'avais pas arrêté de faire ça je
n'aurais pas pu faire dynamite et voilà
j'aime
extrait du nouvel album
qu'ils s'appellent
je
alors qu'eric aide depuis que vous avez
arrêté la cocaïne vous êtes beaucoup
plus agréable avec les journalistes
parce qu'il faut bien voir avec les
paparazzi anglais notamment c'est qu'ils
sont vraiment hyper fort et c'est
vraiment une mue qui veulent me voir
sortir des clubs un peu comme ça
c'est ça qu'ils veulent voir site la
photo qui veulent perdre et donc de
temps en temps il en fut ainsi pendant
tout le monde est content eric et vous
êtes devenu un goût de galles un bon
garçon et on va faire une interview good
guys
[Musique]
est ce que est ce que vous buvez encore
un peu quand même
oui combien son problème votre chronique
pas de problème est-ce que vous fumez
des pétards de temps en temps d'autant
qu'avant mais ça m'arrive de risotto et
banel mais j'en ai besoin après cette
émission est ce que vous êtes passés
devant un juge depuis moins d'un an
oui j'ai passé devant un juge
j'ai perdu mon permis de conduire je les
récupère entre temps mais j'ai permis
donc permis de permis conduite parce que
je faisais trop vite beaucoup trop vite
vous mettez des pots catalytiques à vos
ferrari en fait toutes les ferrari sont
équipées de pots catalytiques
absolument mais si vous partiez des
chapeaux il sera en fourrure synthétique
oui complètement non en fourrure
naturelle jamais jamais est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un goût de gaye est
ce que vous pensez que rien n'est plus
beau que le sourire d'un enfant james
bond mais faut pas exagérer non
alors bon c'est sécuritaire
j'ai toujours bien les les minettes qui
portent des mini jupes et des jeux et
des bottes ajustements justement est ce
que vous demandez toujours la carte
d'identité d'une fan avant de coucher
avec elle pour être sûr qu'elle ait pas
mineur mon dieu non est ce que
maintenant vous êtes un good guys vous
rêvez d'un duo avec mariah carey la
dernière fois que je les ai vus
d'ailleurs elle s'est pointée comme ça
les tuyaux avec que les gens qui
l'entourent eues j'étais là dans le
couloir et les venues elle est passée
comme ça parce que je te fasse du
baisemain est ce qu'on pensait que
l'amour pourrait sauver le monde
si vous débarrasser de georges bush dick
cheney de sur une semaine peut-être que
l'on pourrait sauver le monde
[Applaudissements]
joie
j'allais aux toilettes sont ouverts
entre m
le 22
le 22 mai
oui
[Musique]
la concernant
merci dieu voit comme une call girl
c'est par là c'est le pari skalli et
laurent mais laurent fin risque merde
ok je la fais à londres il faut que tu
leur fais tu verras refait ça lui en
fait l'appareil
[Musique]
j'accueille le hockey
comment ça va très bien à nous on est
crevé un mort à verser fait en biais non
c'est fait jarret parillaud sera pas
réparé t il pas bien parce qu'alors
chose qui clochait je suis en 7e place
et jean pierre raffarin à bon escient un
bonus y en a bien sûr rien
il s'agit pas de but c'est vraiment de
classe et jean pierre raffarin mais on
sait pas où d'un mois la somme alors ans
a très bien très bien heureux de te voir
alors je vais être obligé de vous voyez
pas ce que je vais faire comme si nous
voyons nous voilà alors laurent ruquier
vous animez on a tout essayé tous les
jours sur france 2 un peu avant 19
heures mais également on va se gêner de
16h30 à 18h sur europe 1 tous les après
midis exact est ce que la bonde est la
même pas tout à fait là même qui en plus
à la radio hariri gens qui font pas la
télé qui font la radio comme pierre sled
com
sophie davant tiens c'est la torche et
au tennis et wii
je n'ai pris pendant le match au
téléphone en direct
1 on dirait c'est même thomas fabius qui
tenait le porter à thomas fabius et à la
jean pierre raffarin qui regardaient le
match c'est donc qu'ils contiennent des
amuse pas le verbe il ya ce point de vue
c'est à nouveau et depuis depuis peu de
temps mais non mais la plupart sont
quand même à la télévision c'est vrai on
pas que récemment pressé hier je n'ai
pas de chouchou mais y en a qui ne font
plus rire que d'autres têtes de listes
étaient entre celui qui me fait plus
rire c'est pas secret c'est pierre
bénichou belle et drôle très drôle il
est à la radio la télé lui il fait les
deux alors pour ceux qui peuvent pas
écouté europe1 l'après midi vous publié
chez plon europe 1 on va s'gêner les
meilleurs moments tout ce qui est drôle
quoi
oui c'est vrai d'ailleurs que pierre
bénichou est plutôt bien servi dans ce
bout basile dites moi ce que vous pouvez
faire il ya beaucoup de bénichou ben
jemâa ya des phrases que j'aime de
pierre par exemple quand il dit un
traiteur c'est un charcutier qui s'est
pris pour jean marie messier formule
jade est la fille adoptée par johnny et
laeticia était vachement content de voir
en même temps sa grande soeur et son
grand père arrivé pour venir la chercher
et laurence boccolini qui animait la
soirée les cent femmes les plus belles
du monde il ya christophe alévêque a dit
laurence boccolini ll était 25e et 26e
il ya aussi steevy qui racontent souvent
ses sorties avec martha barrière vous
savez la wii l'héritière du groupe
barrière il est très ami avec milliards
demande à stevie du stv depuis que vous
dînez avec martha barrière est ce que
vous connaissez les règles du savoir
manger quel morceau tu pas tu dois
prendre
est-ce que c'est celui de gauche ou
celui de droite à c'est important quand
on est à table dans société
alors à stevie répond celui qui est à
gauche et bonaldi demande le couteau il
est à droite ou à gauche civis est il
dit à droite et là y'a quelqu'un qui dit
attends ce qui nous intéresse c'est le
sac à main d'ailleurs on a de très
bonnes gérard muller dia lourdes vous
avez remarqué les places de
stationnement celle inverse des villes
habituel d'habitude ya une ou deux
places réservées pour les handicapés
là-bas ce sont une ou deux places pour
ceux qui ne sont pas des dialogues
voilà pour la reine de l'émission voilà
alors ça s'appelle on va s'gêner les
meilleurs moments c'est publié chez plon
en europe 1 et c'est très rigolo voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire moi
je me suis bien marré alors on parle
toujours de le rendre votre
hyperactivité lever et au coucher tard
et vous répondez rassurez-vous j'aime la
vie que je mène d'ailleurs même vous
dites que vous regrettez de ne pas en
faire davantage
je peux pas en faire plus là non mais
vous dites quand je compare ma vie avec
l'avis de la plupart des gens finalement
une existence plutôt heureuse quoi je
vienne pas me plaindre j'ai souvent dit
ça c'est vrai
franchement on est parfois creuser de
soi mais on fait on fait des boulots
formidable on s'amuse pendant qu'on
travaille on va au cinoche au théâtre
gratot enfin je veux dire on n'a que des
avantages dans ce métier oui parfois
c'est fatigant quand on fait beaucoup de
choses mais franchement ceux qui se
plaignent c'est enfin là c'est bien de
s'en rendre compte les artistes qui se
plaignent à des artistes qu'on pas l'air
heureux même après un mariage une horde
à part les impressions que ça les apaise
on apprend la presse au terroir
alors en fait laurent vous n'avez pas
oublié d'où vous venez en fait c'est ça
qui est bien chez vous c'est que vous
souvenez que votre père était ouvrier
chaudronnier au havre que vous habitiez
dans une hlm que vous n'aviez pas de
voiture pas de vacances jusqu'à l'âge de
14 ans après apparemment eu la chance de
pouvoir quitter le cerveau de la chine
pour aller dans une maison de la vallée
pas oublier est en fait en troisième on
vous orienter vers la comptabilité et
vous envisagiez même pas des études
supérieures qua non c'était pas possible
parce que mes parents et cinq enfants
j'étais le dernier et et pour les
parents c'est l'idée c'était que les
enfants travaillent le plus vite
possible donc je suis seul un autre de
mes frères et aller jusqu'au bac mais là
cela pas eu donc je suis le seul à avoir
eu le bac c'était une fierté pour moi
pour mes parents déjà à l'époque il
estimait que après il fallait bosser
quoi bon une fois que j'ai eu mes autres
frères et soeurs m'ont dit et on dit à
mes parents vont maintenant qu'il a le
bac faut qu'il fasse quelques études
supplémentaires
ouais enfin c'est trop tard j'étais déjà
mal orientés non mais l'objectif c'était
quoi c'était de travailler dans un
bureau est pas rentré le soir avec les
mains sales comme opère seul but ma
seule ambition c'était de dire je vais
travailler un jour dans un bureau
pourquoi avoir effectivement j'avais la
vision de mon père qui rentrait crever
qui faisait des heures supplémentaires à
l'époque on avait le droit de faire des
heures supplémentaires et qui pour
nourrir la famille travailler tard le
soir rentrée avec les masses avec son
cuir et on allait chercher ses
cigarettes dans le cuir pour lui faire
plaisir aux fans et voilà c'était
c'était une famille ouvrière et vous
étiez assez résignés finalement à
l'époque j'étais convaincu que ce boulot
d'être comptable c'était ce qui était
fait pour vous c'est
sa tombe est parfaitement moi je
trouvais ça déjà formidable idée de me
dire tiens je vais aller j'ai travaillé
dans un bureau pour moi c'est
extraordinaire et déjà pas travailler à
l'usiné c'était formidable a exactement
alors s'est il résigné mais quand même y
avait quelque part en vous un un désir
d'être journaliste je suis très sérieux
cette interview ok
oui parce que parce que je trouve ça
bien ok d'accord je trouve ça bien parce
que vous êtes sorti de votre classe
sociale ne voulait pas renier
non il n'y a pas de raison en même temps
parfois je me demande si je vais pas
renier parce que j'ai voté oui dimanche
dernier et [__] je m'en veux je me dis
mais j'aurais peut-être dû voter non
parce que manifestement les les gens qui
en ce moment soufre ont voté non alors
voilà est-ce que je me suis trompé je me
pose la question
même après le vote les gens n'ont rien
compris qu'on n'a rien compris avant
pendant et après ce but tu as raison
alors on comprend pas ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui non plus d'ailleurs mais
vous aviez quand même ce désir des gens
et ça se manifester comme ans parce que
c'est vrai qu'au havre dans cette
famille là comment est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer ça d'abord j'ai commencé
à écrire des petits journaux à l'école
je faisais passer pendant pendant les
cours
un petit journal sur lequel je me moquer
des autres élèves et des profs et qu'on
se passer en douce il y avait un
exemplaire unique à ce n'est même pas
imprimer sait comment ça s'appelait
alors c'était en seconde avaient deux
heures s'appelait le journal de la baie
de deux étaient 1 ab j'ai un très
mauvais jeu nous on était là tout
traiter la jetée coupet des trucs dans
des magazines des photos qui ressemblait
plus ou moins aux profs mais je me
foutait de leur gueule pendant le petit
ça a commencé comme ça l'a1
alors c'est résignation vous aviez à
l'époque où vous pensez qu'elle pourrait
revenir un de ces jours je pense que oui
je pense que et je pense que ça pourrait
s'arrêter je serai je serais sûrement
malheureux mais en même temps j'aurais
déjà vécu à des choses que j'aurais
jamais imaginé vivre que je pense que
j'arriverai à survivre et à faire à
peut-être même redevenir comptable allez
savoir
et franchement
[Applaudissements]
votre dernier livre donc s'appelle on va
s'gêner les meilleurs moments et on va
faire une interview on va s'gêner alors
non alors ce qui vous gêne ce qui vous
gêne pas d'accord est ce que ça vous
gêne tous et hétérosexuels qui font la
télévision non ce qui m'emmerde ray ce
qui se reproduisent
est ce que ça vous gêne d'avoir bossé
avec laurent gerra moi ça me gêne pas
lui apparemment ça le gêne semble avoir
oublié ça je pense que j'aurais dû me
méfier quand encore quand on me l'a
livré j'aurais dû bien lire l'étiquette
qui avait dessus méfiez-vous des
imitations à
[Applaudissements]
ça vous gêne d'être responsables de la
présence de steevy et la télévision
pas du tout je suis plutôt fier du
parcours il a réussi à s'imposer en plus
on se souvient quand il est arrivé à
france 2 le taux n'est que ça a provoqué
quelques uns de la télé réalité sur ce
public depuis on voit tous les gens de
la télé réalité partout et puis je
trouve c'est un de ceux qui s'en sortent
plutôt pas mal
il est drôle et des réparties 14 ans je
suis pas responsable
les responsables de steve et à la télé
c'est d'abord m6 et le soft moi j'ai
juste fait l'ablation du bourrique et
c'est tout ça vous gêne et sketch de
dieudonné à dormir dedans parce que j'ai
défendue a abandonné les sketches de
fait ces sketches ne me gêne pas ce sont
ses propos ses interviews ici ou
dandiner des comme j'ai pu lire les
sketchs me
mais je n'ai pas eu des sketches des
proches qui étaient parfois du 2 du même
niveau aussi violent et qui à l'époque
ne choquer personne
le problème c'est qu'il est dit et après
quand on s'aperçoit dans certaines
interviews que on a été trahis un peu
quand on a défendu moi je me suis senti
un peu cocu en fait dans cette affaire
là ça ça m'emmerde
c'est jamais bien de monter une commune
une communauté contre l'autre je me
demande même d'ailleurs s'il n'était pas
à perpignan cette semaine pour faire un
gala ça vous gêne les sdf en bas dans
votre rue j'en ai un unis beau jour tous
les jours dit bonjour monsieur hervé
gaymard il me répond ça vous gêne chirac
président alors chirac président syrien
en tant qu'humoriste ça m'arrange plus
tôt et en tant qu'électeur ça la rend
juil mais oui autrement mois n'ont pas
vraiment un
ça vous gêne la drogue pour écrire j'ai
pas que vous me disiez ça vous gêne
qu'on vous fait draguer par une fille
d'abord ça m'arrive rarement il ya
encore des gens qu'on parle un faux nom
chanel a peut-être un frère ouais ses
origines de gagner beaucoup d'argent
laurent ça fait un peu compliqué je
dirais c'est gênant et ça me gêne pas 1
parce que c'est génial de gagner de
l'argent mais oui parfois ça paraisse on
sent un peu gêné ouais ça vous gêne ne
pas avoir d'enfant à amgen pas vraiment
non ça au moins j'aurai pas un gosse qui
plus tard fera un bouquin en disant que
j'étais un mauvais père ça vous gêne
d'être obligé de faire de l'audience
tous les soirs ça ça me gêne pas d'être
obligé de faire de l'audience parce que
ça me gênait j'irai à canal plus je
serai tranquille web interview tous les
artistes ont l'air gêné quand il parle
de mais en fait on adore ça 1 j'avoue
j'aime de ses autographes
ça me gêne de signer un autographe quand
vous êtes assis à côté de moi et qu on
vous en demande pas vous gêne que
j'espère va y revenir
non ça m'a gêné qui partent de la façon
dont il était parti là je suis plutôt
embarrassé je me demande surtout est ce
qui va avoir assez grand dans sa maison
de l'île de ré pour accueillir françois
hollande ça vous gêne de dire que vous
êtes amoureux
je voulais dit déjà que je vous aime et
thierry mais devant tout le monde
attention il dépose bisou qui traîne à
houla non l'ait pas fait une parillaud
maintenant y avait jarque est l âme
attend et bien ils viennent de se marier
mardi
ça me gêne
mais ces jeunes sont morts c'est gênant
mais j'aurais voulu voir ça avec anne
parillaud je te jure vient de se marier
anne parillaud quand même enfin laurent
non mais c'était pas te balader comme
j'étais un peu tendu un les parties
avant el hadji spa je sais pas tu penses
que fauchon 10 l'article de paris match
sa puce et les éternels gallopin c'est
beau séduire n fera en même temps ça
vous gêne quand on dit du bien de vous
non on pourrait continuer est un peu
mouillé là je vais vous êtes là pour
faire rire aux livres et n'importe quoi
elles seraient bien sûr rattrape toi
c'est leurs parents vont bon on se
connaîtra alors le maire qu'elle est
beaucoup plus en frais thierry mais
alors pourquoi pas franche pas alors on
ira à bègles en voyage de noces
ah ouais conçoit un couple médiatique ça
vous gêne 3 dans un lit
non vous assumez
sexualité vous me foutais là mais pas où
dormir ce soir qu'est ce qui attire ici
ça va mais chocolat belge et la plainte
bleus là on s'entend bien tous les trois
laurent non non ça vous gêne le mariage
gay le mariage gay c'est chiant parce
que si c'est pour épouser un mec est que
ce soit comme une robe de mariée et
qu'on puisse lui rentrer dedans dix ans
plus tard walsh énervement s'étaient
quittées sur le flanc enfants mais la
mission
bon allez
à
méline tu sais que je travaille aussi
pour moi un peu piège mais attention car
tu zapping vous devez tout faire pour
passer au zapping lundi à ces deux
secondes pour être fléchir
[Applaudissements]
une case a bâti il ya des limites non je
crois que ma fille ni décédé les
inquiéter on n'a pas le zapping avec ça
non non tu fais pas d'effort thierry tu
vois on avait fait un autre truc c'est
un truc
qu'est-ce que je peux faire sur alors en
affaires dans la gueule non mais c'est
trop classique à quoi que c'est pas mal
pas mal ça une pelle à une fille hyper
et une fille way
[Applaudissements]
exclu
je ne sais pas qui a choisi attendait
vérifiez d'abord
ah oui
narrow le cas alors ça c'est pas
désagréable
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi il saura pas ce que c'était que
pour moi ah d'accord ap roberto a vu en
rémission n'était pas chaud nicolas je
te jure je te jure que je ne sais pas
mais c'est moi je sais qui c'est ces
crimes et à la fin c'était aussi à
préciser quand même que serge khalfon me
dis que c'est l'ancien chauffeur de
salle qui a amené cette jeune fille
mercy
alors ça donne pas envie de dire et les
nouveaux chômeurs des salles la semaine
prochaine un garçon alors avec elle j'ai
vu que tu mettais la langue tout de
suite
franchement elle est truffée de vous
dire elle est beaucoup plus jolie que je
vous tiens ça ne fait jamais les choses
à moitié monsieur bonne gaule bon mais
je crois qu'on va en rester là pour ce
soir
et maintenant
m
j'accueille olga kurylenko
bonsoir vieux routier
c'est fini mais en portant ses filles
est ce que tu savais que l'ukraine avait
la bombe atomique elle est là voilà la
trouve plus jeudi en encore plus jolie
de plus en plus jolie
moi ça me donne envie de présenter tout
le monde en parle en ukraine quand je
vous vois vous les jouez contre votre
vie oui j'adresse à venir en ukraine
oui en 1979 dans un milieu très pauvre
vous dites j'avais rien à bouffer donc
c'est même pas les hlm du avant
l'arrivée rien à bouffer vraiment
c'était non on avait des fois du pain
sec des patates un mois j'ai pas du
caviar
paducah bien alors vocation précoce vous
avez su que vous vouliez être actrice le
jour où vous avez vu une troupe dans
votre école répéter mais vous étiez trop
petit
oui j'étais trop jeune la maîtresse a
pas voulu oui elle n'a pas voulu parce
qu'elle souhaitait pas ce que fait pas
des enfants de 10 ans voilà est en fait
vous n'écoutez pas ce à l'âge de 13 ans
vous quitter l'ukraine et non pas en
stock
non à quel âge j'ai quitté le cren je
suis parti à moscou quand j'avais 15 ans
mais je vais le dire je le dire vous
allez voir cette femme vient donc vous
quitter l'ukraine à l'âge de 15 ans la
direction
l'escroc direction moscou
vous êtes repéré dans le métro par un
talent scout ça s'est passé comment
adacore alors oui c'est vrai c'était à
13 ans à vous quittez une crème l'âge de
13 ans quitte et je suis allé en
vacances donc vous quitter l'ukraine
pour leurs vacances à moscou une semaine
20e sommet sont tatillons ces gens de
l'air s'est fait gauler oui et donc à
moscou vous êtes repéré dans la banlieue
dans les centres formule sans risque ou
dans le métro de moscou vous êtes repéré
dans un autobus etc
vous êtes repéré par internet scouts et
voilà qu'il me propose de
lettres mannequin et voilà mais voilà
c'est comme ça que vous débutez dans la
carrière de top model c'est incroyable
comme quoi faut prendre le métro pour
faire mal à douala nous leurrer
converture propose les premières la
première fois que je voyais un métro et
métro et les petits escaliers bouge et
vous devenez top model international
pour les plus grandes marques
alors aujourd'hui ça continue parce que
vous êtes la vedette d'un film qui
s'appelle l'annulaire de diane bertrand
avec marc barbé et vous alors le coup de
bol en fait c'est d'avoir été choisi
alors que la réalisatrice ne voulait pas
de mannequin la directrice de casting
parce que vous connaissez
levine j'appelle l'annulaire si le
deuxième long métrage de diane bertrand
qui était adapté du roman de yoko ogawa
alors sinon ce film parce que tout à
l'air réel et pourtant c'est très
étrange je sais c'est ça frôle le
fantastique ainsi c'est toujours comme
ça à la limite c'est filmé de manière
très esthétisante une musique très belle
debetz gibson qui était la chanteuse de
portishead
oui c'est un film sur le désir sur le
day 1a c'est étrange quand même non
c'est un film sur l'amour
ouais alors le pitch assez vagues assez
après s'être fait tranché légèrement
l'annulaire iris c'est vous une jeune
ouvrière quitte son usine pour aller
travailler dans un étrange laboratoire
où elle va connaître une expérience
physique très simple pense on qui dit ça
on va regarder à quoi ça ressemble je
suis chaud bouillant sans presse avant
1 100 watts pendant un mois vous savez
comment on fait pour garder votre caméra
vous dites magnéto serge de voir ça
marche
j'étais quoi magnéto serge sait où la
caméra où il ya le rouge moines et
auxerre c'est pour l'annoncent ce n'est
pas trop tard
en quoi consiste le travail exactement
la laboratoire de ce genre ne se trouve
pas n'importe où c'est pourquoi il faut
un certain temps pour comprendre
[Musique]
entrée une des raisons qui poussent les
gens à nous consulter son différence
pour sa cave ne vont pas les juger
seulement les aider des gens qui
viennent c'est irrégulier
la devise suisse collabore pas
m
pascal
je crois que le travail plus difficile
que je ne pensais
ok
non
et
c'est même
dans ce cas vous vraiment besoin sont
capables d'arriver jusqu'ici les yeux
fermés
[Musique]
en
depuis des jours que je n'ai jamais
apprend avec marc barbé et un gars comme
co que notre invité ce soir voilà ça
sort le 8 juin
alors il ya une montée comme sa
progressive du désir dans le film parce
que la scène de cul n'arrive qu'à la
moitié du film 1 mais oui moi j'ai
regardé j'étais là je l'attendais tour
est attendu
alors si vous êtes bien content elle
très torride la scène vraiment ouais il
ya un truc c'est que votre peau et est
constamment humide à cause de la chaleur
du laboratoire comme ça c'est très
excitant avant très très excitant sema
show ce soir
les gens n'arrêtent pas de baiser chez
eux tiens comme c'est la première fois
qu'on se voie oui on va faire une
interview première fois alors votre
premier souvenir
ma grand mère qui m'apporte un verre de
lait avec des deux gâteaux au lit de
gueule soir votre premier choc choc à
quoi une voiture m'a renversé
vous aviez que l'âge de 11 ans votre
premier mensonge non musulmans tout le
temps aller
c'est jamais fait renverser par une
femme le premier péché par faire l'amour
à qu'elle est mignonne quand votre
premier coup de foudre
jamais jamais jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vrai que cette émission qu avant il
faisait cette émission avec moi et
heureusement tu n'es plus là tu ils
cassent tous les coups il est jaloux
peuvent que je vais embrasser sur la
bouche et blanc je m'intéresse à
quelqu'un de casse pas tous les coups la
première jeune fille 13 07 sur la bouche
sans la langue
c'était à vous savez les camps s'appelle
aller les campagnes heures comme avant
ça existait mais j'étais dans un jamais
jeudi avoir dix 10 ans
en effet la voix et le premier baiser
avec la langue
c'est avec ce garçon de l'allemand cours
de danse le premier flirt poussé avec un
garçon un flirt poussé enfin vous
appreniez les termes le flirt poussé
alors qu'est ce que c'est
enfin l'or poussés et ce depuis lors
j'avais quand même car simon très poussé
sa flore poussées ont fait sauf tous
voila a toujours le même
votre première expérience homosexuelle
ça y est je savais dans les zoos merde
c'est un secret je n'ai pas de nom sacré
combien fois à troyes en fait rien si ce
n'est pas moi à un indice chez vous
première fois quatre à je regardais
premier chagrin d'amour
oui peut-être j'avais 15 ans
on a besoin d'un garçon qui était un
grand succès le danseur c'est vrai mais
j'étais triste mais bon c'est pas un
chagrin parce que comme n'y a jamais eu
au début c'était pas vous avez vous avez
des races et 1 vous allez un peu froide
avec tout ça n'a pas l'air de vraiment
vous passionnez wendy sentimentale que
ça moi comment pourtant vous êtes
scorpionvous non oui un très bien et les
scorpions ça aime le sexe quand même je
vous trouve trop énorme non j'étais
enfant il y en a qui baissent très bon
ménage
elle vous êtes sentimentale quand même
sentimental moi je me demande si vous
être si sentimentale que saab gars
finalement peut-être de temps en temps
des fois ça dépend vous n'êtes pas
amoureuse en ce moment 1
c'est un bon déjà
il dit
[Applaudissements]
attention vous devez porter un grand
chapeau pendant dix minutes le cas ah
oui bah voila je porte un chapeau y vous
allez porter un chapeau et bien oui on a
un très jeune j'avais d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chacun katrina
catherine à 60 ans depuis le 29 mai et
vous dites sexagénaire ça génère du sexe
bah voilà
ça tombe bien vous savez bien le jeu de
mots
ben oui c'est bien c'est fait votre
nouvel adjoint certaines passes - le
ciel avant de parler du nouvel album
didier
[Musique]
l'histoire
m
je
katrina
j'ai manqué non
nous connaissons par coeur
deux chansons
de katrina
lecture sur les standards et c'est
catherine lara houga oui le fait de la
grande artiste française et la nièce de
jean pierre raffarin on peut lire alors
votre nouvel album s'appelle passe moi
le ciel donc alors huit ans en album
solo où vous chantiez est-ce que c'est
dû à une lassitude après 25 albums
besoin d'un break ou d'ailleurs qu'à un
moment donné j'ai un petit peu
l'impression d'arriver comme un cadre
avec mon attaché case et mes nouvelles
petites chansons avec la bonne et la
mauvaise cuvée et je me suis dit là le
break est nécessaire pour retrouver un
team conviction un des mes faire les
choses et de les faire alors tu as envie
d'écrire vous est revenue à travers les
mots avant de vous revenir à travers le
rire est mort parce qu'il y avait très
longtemps que ça me travaillait un petit
peu je n'ai pas fait tout seul ce que
j'avais un partenaire qui est un grand
ce match heures et fait une bonne partie
de ping pong tous les deux voilà
évidemment avec des jeux de mots mais en
essayant de par exemple de sortir de
deux phrases idiotes comme il faut
souffrir pour être belle je trouve tout
positiver s'offrir vous moi je dis il
faut s'offrir ces jolies vérité sort de
la bouche du métro aux siens
oui ça c'est une chanson qui est pas
drôle ça peut faire rire le titre mais
enfin c'est l'histoire d'un sdf
et puis à la traversée du désir veille
alors c'est un album sans artifice un
autre est très ruff comme ça votre votre
voix un peu cassée
bah oui ça l'est le cas s'est arrondi
moi aussi d'ailleurs un bon c'est tout
ça rebondit et puis je crois que c'est
c'est un album mon sérénité c'est
peut-être pas j'ai pas acheté non plus
une auréole est la samare mais je je
dirais que aujourd'hui je me sens bien
dans ma peau et j'avais besoin d'être
bien dans ma peau pour écrire des
chansons très triste parce que s'il est
plus facile d'aller gratter les bleus
qu'on a au fond de l'âme quand on est
bien dans sa peau pour que le premier
single s'appelle petites sommes
c
et
ve
c'est tout
marche ça
l'autre bien
hu
et
c
e
alors qui a fait pschitt chan catherine
un extrait de placement un cierge bel
orlando mais je suis sûr qu'il exigerait
le kitchen si je l'avais vous allez
regarder votre caméra faisait dire my
tho serge manier sauter ge
et
ve
vous serez
m
vva
voilà petit homme essaie de passe-moi le
ciel
tiens tiens voilà c'est en tournée fin
oui un concert à paris probablement
dernier vous paraît bien entendu avec un
orchestre symphonique
ouais voilà plein de projets preach
loire votre autre actualité c g 1 les
gens du grain voilà une adaptation
scénique de l'album éponyme alors ces
histoires de merlin l'enchanteur sur
lancelot guenièvre et c est au monde ça
à montréal en 2006 voilà parce qu'en
fait il n'y a plus aucune commune du
cycle qu'il mars en france vos vacances
un peu fatigué musicale est fatigué donc
on va aller voir ailleurs ce qui se
passe et puis on viendra ici vous avez
déjà eu quand même des gros échec revu
et corrigé de avec bob decout et annie
girardot c'est un gros échec
il n'y avait pas grand monde mais bon
c'était la première fois on est elle est
un peu les pionniers dans l'histoire
n'est pas encore tout à fait instaurer
et puis les romantiques moi j'avais le
goût de grandeur il y avait cinquante
musiciens sur scène parce que je voulais
pas de bande et au bout de dix jours
évidemment le budget est un peu ma voix
là mais je les fais c'était beau le
châtelet était plein et on a vécu un
instant merveilleux
ce qui est formidable c'est qu'après ces
deux gros échec et malgré l'insuccès de
beaucoup de comédies musicales en france
vous ayez quand même envie de monter
grave
oui on vient de faire cent mille albums
c'est pas si mal les romantiques on
avait fait aussi 150 mille albums c'est
pas des échecs cuisants 1
c'était le début il faut le temps c'est
un état d'esprit qui est pas tout à fait
encore restauré en france alors qu'ils
aient commencé notre carrière en
accompagnant mireille mathieu nana
mouskouri juliette gréco est ce que ces
femmes qui vous ont donné envie d'aider
mais des femmes non non non c'est ça ça
vient pas de la même façon que mireille
mathieu suscite des vocations
on va passer mais moi j'aime les êtres
et puis ça vient de toute petite j'ai
toujours aimé je suis attiré par les
belles personnes sans distraction ouais
alors j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone cet
après midi de votre attaché de presse
oui tu m'as dit cherry ne lui dit pas
cette phrase qu'on vous répète à chaque
fois ai-je façon je l'aurais pas fait
quand je regarde un homme la première
chose que je regarde c'est sa femme et
non
c'est sa mère maintenant d'une agence
appelée pour me dire de ne pas vous
poser la question bon ben tout va bien
je l' ai dit et puis c'était plutôt
drôle à l'époque je vous pose pas la
question
mais non mais tout va bien l'interview
garçon manqué vous connaissez qui comme
joueur en équipe de france je connais si
vous voyez plus un payer plus bon bah
maintenant aujourd'hui je suis pas bien
je serai capable de dire m
c'était quand votre dernière bagarre je
me bagarre pas tellement ça vous tente
un petit bras de fer oui non
avec moi et la langue jamais faire c'est
du jeu de brut
les coudes sur la table mais j'ai pas
gilles va pas juste envers bella
l'attention 1-2 turquie fait surface
qu'il existe un geste gagner
catherine est ce que vous seuls est ce
que vous savez changer la roue d'une
voiture
oui est ce que ces sifflets avec vos
doigts ce qui vous arrive de boire une
bière en regardant un match de l'équipe
de france de football arrive le boring
bière en regardant pas mal de choses oui
éventuellement est-ce que vous tirerez
veille le dimanche matin pour regarder
téléfoot excuse est forte en créneau
vous regardez quoi en premier chez une
fille ces prix tout l'humour qui matière
déjà profité qu'une fille soit bourré
pour coucher avec n'ont jamais non c'est
pas mon truc n'a pas du tout déconne sa
marge au poids mais c'est pas mal
finissante mans est plus sympathique ça
vous énerve quand votre copine passe des
heures à se préparer
oui c'est vous surprend qu'une fille
n'ai pas envie de faire l'amour parce
que la migraine j'ai pas vraiment connu
ça j'ai déjà trompé votre copine en
disant c'est juste pour le sexe ben oui
vous quitteriez une fille parce qu'elle
est nul au lit j'ai vous savez j'ai pas
un regard d'homme sur les femmes 1
je suis une femme mais j'ai un regard de
femme sur les êtres en général mais
voilà
m
le haras
seul
jean noël
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
alalala chat ça serait bien la carte
fellation à vous gagnez une n'ont laissé
tombé ses fans
[Rires]
c'est une fausse carte en fait c'est une
fausse car comment ce bal était bien
c'est dommage
[Musique]
vous devez dire du mal de se re emmanuel
au franchement c'est pas possible
aussi c'est bien ça non c'est pas bien
de quoi parce que cette conne c'est une
femme je me sens incapable de faire ça
j'ai un tel respect pour cette fois oui
ah non dire du mal de soleil pas a dit
du mal de mère teresa on s'en fout non
mais bon je peux lui dire que sa corne
est lui va pas bien non non non pas du
mam et non me dire du mal c'est
impossible de dire du mal d'une femme
aussi parfaite
tu sais ce que c'est quand on fait je
veux pas faire la carte on doit
embrasser quelqu'un olga et sur la fée
tout à l'heure je n'ai jamais d'abord il
veut passer certaines banques je veux
bien passer sans problème
mais beaucoup de buts andré mignon que
tout à l'heure
chaque à lci mme gilbert
m
[Musique]
lee
bonsoir philippe gilbert vous êtes
informaticiens vous vivez à lussac
saint-émilion en gironde
mais depuis de nombreuses années vous
passer plusieurs semaines par an au sri
lanka où vous étiez le jour du tsunami
vous raconter cette aventure dans un
livre qui s'appelle les larmes de ceylan
aux éditions des équateurs alors le 26
décembre 2004
vous êtes donc dans le sud de l'île de
ceylan dans un bungalow vous ai fait
construire dans un village de pêcheurs
près de temps gaulle vous y vivez quatre
mois par an il est amoureux de ces
langues est tombé amoureux de ceylan
vous avez des amis sri lankais notamment
m/h parce qu'il préfère qu'on appelle
comme ça et kamina sa femme ils ont une
petite fille aux syndicats 7 ans qui
joue avec votre petite fille juliette
qui a quatre ans voilà en effet delphine
votre fille et jérôme votre gendre sont
venus passer des vacances à un scellant
qui me ce matin là votre gendre vous
propose d'aller pêcher mais avant il va
faire le marché attend gaulle avec votre
fille les 9 heures vous surveillez les
deux fillettes elles dessinent et là une
touriste qui loue une chambre chez un
mach votre voisin sri lankais est
surprise par une vague que vous
qualifiez de téméraires dans votre livre
et se réfugie dans le jardin et vous
l'aidez à ce moment là vous avez le
sentiment qu'il se passe quelque chose
d'extraordinaire où vous trouvez ça
presque naturel non à ce moment là je
trouve cela tout à fait naturel je suis
habitué à voir la vague de temps en
temps vous allez chez le bord du bus à
l'eau donc n'en mange pas du tout
surpris par surprise alors l'eau passe
la clôture du petit jardinet vous
réagissez pas plus à à ce moment-là vous
rentrez dans votre bungalow pour pas
être mouillé
hélas le le flot d'eau s'engouffre
dans la pièce en fréquence en tout sur
son passage dire que la la la porte
d'entrée vole en éclats quoi là vous
comprenez qu'il se passe quelque chose
de willa à ce moment là je prends
conscience
même si j'ai pas conscience totale de ce
qui va réellement se passer quelques
secondes après là je commence à
comprendre que ce n'est pas normal
vous comprenez qu'il se passe quelque
chose il ya un deuxième flou qui
torrentielles dit vous vous avait de
l'eau jusqu'au cou et vous vous sortez
du du bungalow où vous êtes réfugiés et
dehors la vision est absolument
terrifiante il ya une vague monstrueuse
et vous avez cette image vite j'ai
l'impression d'être comme un égyptien
dans le film les 10 commandements au
moment où la mer rouge se referme
kouassi à vous est submergé par la part
la masse d'eau c'est ça c'est ça ma
première pensée ça a été tu vas pas
souffrir ouais ouais quand vous voyez un
truc comme ça
là vous pensez que vous allez mourir à
ce moment-là arriver j'en suis tout à
fait persuadé je suis simplement rassuré
à l'idée que ça va ça va ça va aller
très vite que je souffrais pas pour moi
je suis mort heureusement voilà vous
êtes transporté à 30 mètres de chez vous
et heureusement vous accrocher un
cocotier et là vous vous prenez comme ça
quoi comme une espèce de deux bouées de
sauvetage c'est le cas de le dire et
vous laisser passer la vague et vous
parvenez à continuer à respirer donc à
survivre tout ça se passe très vite
vraiment très très vite et après une
fois que vous êtes accroché
c'est interminable faut que ça cesse
faut que ça cesse et que ça cesse voilà
et aux enfants étaient en sécurité
la chance de ma fille et de mon gens
c'est qu'ils étaient partis au marché ce
jour là une heure tout à fait
inhabituelle d'habitude qui partent au
marché beaucoup plus tard que ça là ils
sont partis et d'habitude ils emmènent
juliette avec eux et là je le redis vu
leur laisser juliette elle est avec aux
110 tranquille décès je vais les garder
vous demandez donc ou sans eau sans dit
la fille de vos amis sri lankais et
juliette
oui il faut savoir que la vue le
spectacle auquel j'ai assisté je n'ai
pas le moindre doute sur le fait que
juliette et aux 110 soit soit morte ne
peuvent pas avoir je vois à la chambre
où elle était joint il ya un bateau
dedans il ya à face et c'est donc je
n'ai plus de doute là dessus maintenant
il me reste un truc terrible affaire
c'est d'annoncer ça m'a fait il de
revenir si vous voulez
d'aller vers eux et d'affronter le
regard de ma fille qui va me voir
arriver moi vivant tout seul sans sa
fille l'a effectivement voulais
retrouver sur le marché de temps gaulle
ils sont même pas mouillé évidemment
puisque c'est à des kilomètres de là
vous dit jamais je n'oublierai le cri de
delphine un cri dément insoutenable oui
rien d'autre à rajouter ça m'a marqué
pour le restant de mes jours
alors ensuite vous allez dans un hôtel
qui est situé à 7 km de temps gaulle sur
les hauteurs un hôtel qui s'appelle eva
lanka et là vous êtes choqués parce
qu'en fait les touristes évidemment ils
savent pas ce qui s'est passé donc ils
profitent de la journée de vacances
comme si de rien n'était et nous on
arrive là enfin encore que ma fille et
mon gendre était correctement habillés
mais en ce qui me concerne j'étais en
loques en sang ça fait un drôle d'effet
un de le voir qu'il ya des gens qui ont
pu ne pas se rendre compte du tout de ce
qui s'était passé
voyez une personne qui concerne est
quand même celle n devynck de lci qu'il
a avec son compagnon emmanuel carrère
l'écrivain oui et elle vous parlez vous
témoigner sur lci de ce qui s'est passé
en fait ce jour là
oui et ça ça a été le départ de tout ça
a été
si vous utilisez des mots comme ça dans
notre situation c'est une chance inouïe
une chance inouïe parce que si vous
voulez il est évident qu'on aurait de
toute façon aider les les très proches
amis de ne serait-ce que de cette sortie
de ça mais là le fait que j'ai été par
chance le premier à témoigner
ça a tout de suite amené les médias vers
nous quand on est rentré en france
bon c'est pas trop trop mon style de
jouer avec ça mais là je crois que
j'avais pas le choix il fallait que je
sois très con pour ne pas jouer à ce jeu
donc on a laissé les articles paraître
dans paris match
on a même été jusqu'à accepter qu'une
photo de juliette 70 soit diffusé
c'était pas de gaieté de coeur mais je
crois que c'était le seul moyen pour
comment récolte la somme maximale nous
permettant d'aider non plus une deux
trois familles mais quelque 50 ou 100
familles puisque c'était notre objectif
à partir de ce moment là alors est-ce
que vous découvrez à ce moment là c'est
qu'il est impossible de rapatrier le
corps de votre petite fille juliette
pour la faire incinérer en france cesser
purement interdite oui il faut le faire
au sri lanka et un jour vous irez jeter
les cendres de juliette dans un jardin
botanique à kandy près d'un massif de
bougainvilliers alors vous vivez depuis
avec une espèce de culpabilité vous vous
dites évidemment j'aurais pu la sauver
alors il ya une chose qu'on prend pas
bien dans le livre quand la vague
arriver ce qu'elle est sur la terrasse
de votre bungalow sur la terrasse du
bungalow mhl et/ou escale dans une pièce
de la maison de votre voisin une dizaine
de mètres derrière moi même pas enfin
ivan gayton une dizaine de mètres
derrière moi dans une dans une chambre
une chambre d'hôte si vous voyez un
jouet avec sa petite copine 70 y a dit m
lundi m vous l'aviez sous les yeux à ce
moment là j'avais aucune raison à ce
moment là j'ai eu avant que la vague
arrive de les surveiller de très près
c'est un endroit très très très en
sécurité un essai vraiment c'est un
véritable paradis donc aucune raison de
les surveiller après que d'habitude
par contre après entre le moment où la
vague but arriver dessus le moment je me
suis retrouvé trente mètres plus loin
avec le accroché comme un coin ce
cocotiers je peux même pas dire que j'ai
pensé à ce moment là au soleil à julien
je peux le temps j'ai pas vu j'ai pensé
à rien strictement rien voilà alors là
vous commencez avec votre gendre jérôme
a échafaudé une association pour aider
les habitants de ce petit village de
pêcheurs vous inventer ce qu'on appelle
le kit de nécessité a lancé quoi
exactement savez ça consiste en d'abord
on s'improvise 1 on n'a jamais fait un
moniteur donc vous arrivez avec un trac
pas possible en vous demandant si
vous allez être à la hauteur parce que
c'est quand même pas le droit de se
planter
et puis vous allez à l'essentiel
vous distribuez des feuilles de papier
dans le village et vous dites aux gens
en fait vous vous prenez le active et a
besoin de quoi oui la commande quoi tu
as besoin de quoi on n'est pas les
blancs sauveur venant à la rescousse de
cette non là on
on se fait tout petit de quoi tu as
besoin et on s'aperçoit ça va très vite
c'est en quelques jours les besoins sont
toujours les mêmes
un lit un matelas et ça ça a pris une
importance terrible après vous verrez un
moustiquaire des ustensiles de cuisine à
la bullet il ya des besoins sa fin c'est
vraiment élémentaire leur rendre leur
dignité
en fait voilà attention la plupart des
familles non non non plus de toi non
plus deux mais au delà du fait qu'elle
n'ait plus de toit et plus de maison
elles mangent des feuilles de journaux
et les enfants dorment par terre sur les
ruines des maisons et ça je les ai vu de
mes yeux vu là vous vous dites ya
urgence
alors vous cherchez pas à vous organiser
or ce fut partait au quart de tour vous
foncez alors vous fait des bêtises
vous n'etes et quatre jours à équiper 10
familles parce que vous pensez qu'il
faut faire le tour des commerçants etc
etc
et après on devient un petit peu moins
bête on se dit bamba s'organiser on va
distribuer les tickets aux gens ils vont
aller eux-mêmes dans les boutiques tout
ça se met en or bon il faut reconnaître
aussi qu'on a là affaire à un peuple
qui n'a pas du tout la mentalité des
peuples occidentaux
on est sur des gens qui sont face à ce
malheur d'une dignité déjà absolue
extrêmement réservé pas du dia pas de
panique une scène de panique
alors que faut pas oublier que là on est
au bout du au bout de la première
semaine on sait qu'on va avoir 700
familles à l'équipe et on a coupé là ça
y est on le sait on va voir on va on a
mis une frontière si vous voulez medac
et tire mais c'est horrible déjà ça
cette frontière rien il veut dire bats
toi tu étais petit l'autre côté de la
route tu rentres pas dans le monde c'est
celle là
voilà vous vous mettez au boulot avec
jérôme pour essayer de les aider est en
revanche pas de trace de ong vous dit où
sont les dons où sont les 20 tonnes de
médicaments a mené dans sept airbus 310
ça a coûté trois cent mille euros pour
la pour acheminer les dons vous voyez
rien voyez des 4,4 flamboyant dites vous
des 4 4 9 de la croix-rouge et vous
dites qu'une de ses voitures vous
permettrait avoue enfin tous les cas aux
gens du sri lanka de reconstruire sans
maison dans l'avion on se on
s'inquiétait de savoir comment on allait
pouvoir nous tous petits là on a les
gangs et de guérilla s'entendre avec
toutes ces ong sur place
ouais parce que comme vous on a entendu
que il y avait
des dons faramineux que toutes les ong
étaient là bas que se dit comment on va
trouver notre place la has a pas été
difficile on était tout seul ouais on
était tout seul quand je suis arrivé au
début février on était tout seul quand
j'eus quand mon gendre est parti fin
avril absolument personne
c'est incroyable parce que la france a
envoyé 190 millions d'euros
alors il paraît que l'argent est placé
dans les sicav monétaires comme ça c'est
un véritable scandale d'accord quand je
lis moi dans le parisien c'est monsieur
mais t il lui même qui le dit que il a
pour lille à 30 de la croix rouge après
avoir été patron de la canicule chez
voilà il à 100 millions de dons et à
aujourd'hui ils ont dépensé 7 1
il ya quand même quelque chose
d'absolument obscènes à détourner de
cette façon l'argent que les gens ont
donné pour le sri lanka la thaïlande le
laos est absolument scandaleuse
oui il ya 7 % des sommes qui ont été
données au sri lankais le reste ils
n'ont pas vu voilà moi je ne je ne
remets pas en cause la bonne foi de ces
gens je dis c'est de la bêtise mais en
même temps c'est tout à fait scandaleux
donc il faut demander des comptes à la
croix rouge bien sûr eh bien on va
appeler le docteur robert sebag
[Musique]
m
il
bonsoir alors cet administrateur
national la croix-rouge votre fonction
en fait c'est de faire la somme des dons
reçus de savoir comment l'argent est
dépensé
les missions sur le terrain c'est moins
votre truc enfin ce qu'un vous qui gérez
le pognon j'en ai fait une voie là alors
où est l'argent ou et le pognon alors ce
que je peux vous assuré il ya une partie
de l'argent qui a été dépensé et il ya
une programmation on a signé sans en ce
qui vous concerne on est d'accord il ya
soixante dix régions
non mais vous dit combien cette sur 107
sur 100 millions alors oui il avoue sur
les 93 millions
il ya 70 millions d'euros qui sont
engagés aujourd'hui il ya mille maisons
deux hôpitaux au sri lanka en indonésie
à l'approvisionnement en eau qui se fait
dans la région d'ankara dans la région
dans la région de galles vous le savez
il faut des bureaux il faut une
logistique en indonésie on a plus plus
plus de 50 personnes qui sont sur place
il ya eu le tremblement de terre sur
l'île niasse on a été tout de suite là
on a remis 10 litres d'eau par personne
et par jour 160 mille litres d'eau à
filtrer il fallait transporter le
matériel
alors l'argent il est pas dépenser en
immédiat il est pas dépenser comme sale
argent et pourquoi
mais mes sessions de quoi vous avec les
autres il vous faut des récipiendaires
il faut des gens de confiance vous
pouvez pas distribuer l'argent à
n'importe qui vous connaissez ce pays
comme dans le coup que philippe gilbert
mais non mais pourquoi est ce que les
braves pêcheurs qui ont eu tout détruit
on leur dit pas à chacun on vous donne
je sais pas moi
dix mille dollars pour acheter un bateau
pour acheter on est en train ce qu'on
n'a jamais fait si vous voulez d'avoir
des partenaires locaux des associations
là on vérifie qu'elle s'est faite entre
non mais c'est en vidéo entend des
choses comme ça vous êtes donc c'est
bien parce que votre discours au moins
il est honnête vous vous êtes en train
de faire un constat d'échec là c'était
incroyable c'est un jour démontre je
vais retourner au mois de juillet au sri
lanka à côté de medhatiyah en jeu rien
d'un héros qui vont comparer manger dans
l'événement le journe audrey
70 millions excusez moi docteur et n'en
attendez attendez il est en question il
n'est pas question de mettre ici en
doute l'efficacité est là et la probité
de la croix rouge c'est pas du tout
notre propos efficacité un peu quand
même
tous les cas d'un coup rouge a fait ses
preuves depuis depuis plus d'un siècle
pour dire ce que je veux dire simplement
voilà ce que je me disais docteur ce que
dit philippe gilbert il dit voilà il dit
moi je vais retourner parce que c'est un
amoureux de s'élancer plus qu'un
touriste c'est un mec a construit une
baraque là-bas gilbert bon donc il va
aller là bas il va voir ces gens qui
vont continuer à bouffer dans des
comédies dans des journaux à dormir sur
des ruines
alors que vous vous avez fait pas des
millions et des millions d'euros sur des
placées en sicav nés de mères c'est ça
qui concerne un sujet pareil
vraiment je veux pas polémiquer surtout
pas avec vous ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'on a repéré un certain nombre
d'associations locales vous même je vous
le dis je le dis je lis devant tout le
monde
je veux dire nous sommes tout à fait
prêts sur votre association parce que
vous êtes quelqu'un de confiance de
votre village vous avez vécu vous avez
construit à financer un projet je le dis
c'est pas c'est pas le chemin que j'ai
dit j'ai pris devant vous avez raison il
faut de l'argent jeu important mais
c'est très très long vous être submergé
excusez moi je ne vaux par la
bureaucratie quoi mais la bureaucratie
locale aussi la bureaucratie locale
faire des virements d'argent locaux à
voir les dédouanements vous savez que
même sur des médicaments d d d d d
ddd filtreurs d'eau on doit à la douane
on doit payer un certain nombre de taxes
tout est contrôlé vous pouvez pas rués
pour une énorme face à une catastrophe
comme si vous envoyez des églises par la
nôtre des petites équipes de rien d'une
jeune fille pousse à dire que je disais
moins région quand vous allez arriver à
l'aéroport
vous allez vous n'allez pas dire que
vous êtes une ong vous allez dire vous
êtes touristes ça nous permettait de
rentrer tranquillement dans le pays si
jamais vous disiez ong et vous bloquer
et vous restiez quinze jours à colombo
je vienne où on passait comme touristes
on a ouvert un compte en banque tout de
suite là bas on fait on faisait virer
l'argent la barre les faits on allait
monter des équipes avec des strings
payer mais je sais j'en limites avec
tout l'argent mis à jouer et même des
gens c'est simple je dis cela en mairie
ils roupies par jour à chaque sait dans
quelle branche mannequin c'est décevant
je me dis à bientôt nous nous en a nous
on a fait je la retiens ici les gens
comptent donner sur ces légendes aux
plaisirs rapidement et quand on touche
là secourus dans cette ville à la une en
temps quand on sort les âges sans fond
se joue de fric et on se demande
toujours où va le pognon à la croix
rouge tout mis en confiance on mange on
est en jeu vous allez il faut aussi jugé
les programmes qu'ils ont faits qui ont
lieu aujourd'hui au sri lanka
vous n'êtes pas tomber sur les villages
mais je le dis et je le répète notre
association mais non écoutez vous
connaissez comme moi le sri lanka
la cote était non je dis vous pas
remettre en question on va construire
1000 maisons on va construire trois
centres hospitaliers
il ya vingt-cinq personnes ont mis la
maison avec il ya urgence à faire là bas
on est aussi en indonésie
on est aussi le pays où il ya eu
personnes en somalie parce que la
somalie était tout seul n'a pas parlé
avant par fabien semaine non mais ce que
tu urgence et de lits des matelas
ces deux moustiques heures aujourd'hui
pour résumer la situation en suisse où
tu vas quand même pas pourquoi
avec l'argent en tout cas vous ne payez
pas des gens tous montrés d'accord pour
payer d engager des gens payés l'ag
d'hier mardi son chômage envers ce pays
et je vous assure qu'on envoie
effectivement dans le poujadisme et donc
à fait du passage du tour et pendant ce
temps là sont les banques qui sont du
pognon avec l'argent qui est dessus mais
sur les comptes
les sicav monétaires
pas du tout mais pas vous pouvez pas
vous pouvez pas déverser vous pouvez pas
déverser sur un pays 25 millions d'euros
comme ça tout d'un coup donc tout
l'argent je peux vous assurer c'est de
l'argent l'argent l'argent qui est
l'argent qui n'est pas dépensé tous les
intérêts sont reversés au programme asie
vous savez très bien que les période de
reconstruction
ça va durer longtemps encore à les
remettre en cause le but au bout de chou
non ce que après le tremblement de terre
en iran il ya aujourd'hui encore des on
est les seules organisations étaient
près la croix rouge française
on n'a pas eu beau en est beaucoup moins
d'argent que le tsunami avec présence
urbam aujourd'hui à monter un certain
nombre de programmes
je vous dis on vous connaît ans et un
rouge mais gens méchants enchaînement
véritable nom mais mais mais là je ne
peux pas non plus très mal organisé hier
des volontaires c'est pas un problème
d'organisation des morts des visas mais
on peut pas faire n'importe quoi
on a aussi des comptes à rendre parle
pas les genres s'est retiré mais bien je
suis d'accord mais quand vous avez des
partenaires comme monsieur on est tout à
fait prêt je le redis à aider
spécifiquement son village mais c'est
passé c'est ainsi annoncé mais lui c'est
pareil
mais la part où j'avais une vision
d'ensemble plus et bien sûr si l'on créé
pour que quelqu'un vous êtes ça c'est
bien ils entendirent salamat nos sens
nos relations mais c'est pas le sas et
voudrait revoir des deux villages
réponse à mes vous pour avoir des
témoins deux visages
les vrais faisait défaut aider tout le
monde on pourrait on pourrait avoir ici
en face des villageois dans lesquels
nous sommes présents
on a fait des mini 10 j'espère mais je
dirais merci à la croix-rouge bonne
blague merci heureusement que jamais
l'organisation façon à les chasser
qu'est-ce que je qu'est-ce que vous
parce que c'est ça qui est important
vous vous habiter là-bas vous y allez
plusieurs mois par an vous êtes encore
une fois vraiment sri lankais d'esprit
pour qu est ce que vous pensez qu'il
faut faire qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
je pense qu'il faut faire moi je crois
que je viens de m'exprimer suffisamment
sur le sujet jeu est tout simplement il
faut que l'argent qui aujourd'hui d'or
dans des banques soient utilisées d'une
façon ou d'une autre alors c'est comme
le dit fort justement laurent ruquier
s'est par exemple payer chômeurs en
france et tant pis si on fait du
poujadisme parce que là c'est à dire en
plus
bon ou tout simplement le le distribuer
il ya n'a pas besoin d'autant que vous
en avez des petites associations comme
nous qui vont au moins essayer de faire
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire de ramener très
vite ces villages a dit parce que quand
vous dites mon village il votre village
je peux vous assurer que j'ai fait la
route de colombo à je sais vous vous
étiez vous étiez plutôt sur la côte est
d'accord bien trafic alors voilà voilà
mais toute la côte qui est là je peux
vous dire que les gens n'ont pas été
aidé du tout c'est dire toute la côte
entre colombo et en gal est en mode
total n'a pas été aidé du tout gaulle
par exemple ça pas été non c'est qu' à
ce qui a été fait non c'est dans ces
villes c'est la plupart du temps on a
travaillé sur le plan hôpitaux
voilà là il ya eu beaucoup de choses de
faites donc ça je remets pas ça en
question mais c'est pas parce qu'on
construit un hôpital qu'il faut laisser
les gens dans la merde aux bords de
l'eure au bord de l'eau vous voyez bon
voilà et surtout ce qui me choque c'est
que c'est des sommes faramineuses on
entend parler alors que nous avec cent
mille euros c'est une goutte d'eau on a
redonné à 700 familles la dignité
élémentaire dont ils avaient besoin
c'est vrai que voilà on randonne
volontiers en france et ailleurs
derrière dans les pays occidentaux
c'est vrai qu'à un moment on est en
droit de demander des comptes aux
organisations non gouvernementales en
était en droit de vous demander ce que
vous faites de l'argent et il ya un
autre problème qui se pose c'est aussi
un bouquin qui vient de sortir
j'accueille andrew thompson
oui
ouais
il
bonsoir bonsoir en eau thompson jette
néo zélandais
vos parents était missionnaire dans les
îles salomon et fidji vous vous étiez
médecin dans un hôpital à auckland où
vous rencontrez un médecin cambodgiens
qui vous parle de sa vie sous les khmers
rouges voilà la famille le travail forcé
les exécutions le génocide
à partir de là dans votre hôpital
d'auckland vous lisez tous les livres
que vous pouvez trouver sur le sujet et
vous voyez un film très important qui
est la déchirure
le film de roland joffé alors au bout de
trois ans d'incertitude vous vous rendez
compte que votre vie finalement n'est
pas si si utile que ça et vous décidez
de partir au cambodge selon une formule
qui vous a été apprise par vos parents
accéder au bonheur en servant les autres
une très belle très belle formule alors
d'abord vous travaillez à la croix rouge
ensuite à l'onu et là vous découvrez une
réalité très négative pour le nu c'est
ce que vous racontez avec deux camarades
dans un livre intitulé il faut sauver la
planète
3 idéaliste dans l'enfer humanitaire qui
est publié chez payot alors quand on
vous dit mais comment osez vous cracher
dans la soupe de l'humanitaire comment
osez vous dire du mal de l'onu dont la
mission est quand même d'apporter la
paix réconfort à tous les atouts les
terriens vous dites nous avons risquer
notre vie et vu nos amis mourir au nom
de l'humanitaire nous avons donc le
droit de dire la vérité voilà c'est pour
ça que vous avez fait ce bouquin avec
kenneth qu'est né et d'y poster weight
qui sont des gens qui comme vous
travaillez à l'onu alors vous quand le
livre est sorti ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que vous avez été viré de l'onu où vous
étiez médecin vous a été obligé de faire
un scandale médiatique pour que votre
pour que votre contrat soit renouvelé à
l'onu bon finalement vous êtes resté
mais enfin il a quand même fallu aller
chercher des lobbyistes à washington
pour faire un scandale voilà voilà
alors vous avez été témoin de plusieurs
choses je dirais d'abord l'argent mal
dépensé c'est que quand vous arrivez au
cambodge
par exemple on est prêt à dépenser
2 millions de dollars pour organiser des
élections et ces élections vous vous
savez qu'elles sont pas vraiment utiles
à ce moment là oui c'était juste après
la chute du mur de berlin il y avait
tellement de petits musées et l'onu
étaient censés d'arrêter tous ces
conflits liés à la guerre froide dans le
premier conflit c'est le cambodge et
puis c'est incroyable de voir vingt
mille casques bleus 2 milliards de
dollars on n'était pas mieux kennedy et
moi 2 millions de dollars pour organiser
des élections dans un pays comme le
cambodge si tu veux tu en avais donné
ces deux millions de dollars à chaque
cambodgien aujourd'hui roulera en
mercedes quoi je dire bon voilà alors ça
c'est une des premières choses que vous
découvrez ensuite vous découvrez que
l'argent est parfois détournés quand
vous êtes en somalie parce que vous
faites tous les tous les endroits
évidemment chauds de la planète
vous découvrirez un français qui
organise un tribunal
en fait sans raison non plus il n'y a
pas de raison d'organiser un tribunal à
ce moment là simplement parce que lui
prend de l'argent sur la constitution de
ce tribunal
mais c'est vrai en fait c'est mon coach
kane qui était en sous main aller avec
arrêt dit l'autre et son chef a organisé
un programme d'ouvrir une tribune en
somalie mais en plein guerre il y avait
une guerre entre les
liste dite et les géants américains pour
c'est une idée fort mais pop et les
salaires du juge sur mali avec l'agent
l'onu et les chefs de kent a tourné cet
agent je pars à 20% a mis dans les
poches
alors il a risqué la vie de kien parce
qu'il y avait une grosse bataille autour
de cette tribunal et puis voilà qu'il
avait envie de tuer son chef après ça
alors il ya aussi vous raconter
l'utilisation par le nu de troupes
absolument inadaptée présente les
bulgares j'allais les bulgares reçoivent
de l'argent de l'onu en échange de quoi
ils donnent des troupes qui deviennent
des casques bleus mais les bulgares vous
dit enfin ils envoient des fois des gens
qui sortent des hôpitaux psychiatriques
quoi qu'ils se comportent après d'une
façon absolument aberrante quand ils
sont sur le sur le lieu des opérations
et en amis ça donne un livre juste pour
montrer le type de casque bleu qui
arrive à l'onu mais c'était une minorité
oui j'y passe était mais le problème est
que 7,7 et qu'ils n'étaient pas
disciplinés dont ils violaient les
femmes cambodgiennes il avait des
bagarres avec des khmers rouges et il
était censé assurer notre sécurité donc
un ami de paragraphes dans le livre
juste pour montrer sa wii
et puis quand le livre est sorti à un
nom à new york
il y avait tellement de polémique sur ça
je crois que le gouvernement bulgare a
porté plainte auprès de l'onu
on était traité de menteur mais qu'est
ce qu'on voit un an après c'est
scandaleux sexe contre nourriture eau
comme the wheel à l'épidémie des viols
des changes de nourriture pour le sexe
parmi nos troupes sur amadea sinde
scandale en ce moment ce sens dans le
livre bien sûr mais c'est un livre très
important parce que c'est la première
fois que que trois personnes qui ont
fait partie l'eau est venus raconte sa
dérision eu plein de problèmes
il ya aussi les troupes nigérianes qui
se comporte au liberia à l'ecomog cyr
qui sont envoyées au libéria pour
maintenir l'ordre
port d'une façon absolument incroyable
ils pillent volent ils violent les
femmes enfin ces soit disant ils sont là
pour l'onu mais doit il faut dire
qu'après la l'échec
on se marie avec cet épisode de chute du
faucon noir les américains se sont
retirés d'une très jeune président
clinton et ya perdu et du courage
tanguy y ait plus de trucs américain
dans ses missions de maintien de paix
alors les nigériennes étaient comme vous
dites reviennent sens et d'assurer sa et
puis ils sont pas sûrs et la paix ils
ont fait du combat pour contrôler les
mines de diamants pendant que l'ex pas
vraiment des casques bleus m elle exige
le maintien de paix qui se bat pour les
pierres précieuses
il ya l'utilisation de l'argent des
troupes de mauvaise qualité qui sont
enrôlés sous le casque bleus de l'onu et
puis vous raconter la grande vie la
dolce vita
parce que évidemment à phnom penh quand
les fonctionnaires de l'onu arrive ils
vont dans les hôtels les plus chers
évidemment le cambodge poney était une
mission plein d'optimisme quand je
disais non et puis on a travaillé dieu
les l'enjeu et quand on fait la fête on
faisait la fête
donc je crois que dans ces zones de
guerre quand on n'est pas sûr de vivre
le lendemain
reset jacques mary j quand même sur ben
envie d'une façon intense donc pour se
soulager pour sauter toute cette tension
ont fait la fête en bois un fume des
joints y avait une super cocktail du
cognac et marois n'est qu'en faisait
qu'on appelle soucoupes volantes
comprendre que de ça et puis on est
juste en train de flotter
donc vous dites par exemple un homme
peignent des flottes de voitures
extrêmement cher c'est exactement ce que
dit philippe gilbert au sujet du
sri-lanka dire qu'il ya eu 6000 land
cruiser quoi ce que 6000 land cruiser ce
comme des voitures qui valent une
fortune 6000 c'est beaucoup vous parlez
des bars des restaurants des salons de
massage vous dites avec des fils de dix
voitures devant est votre ami kane qui
co écrit le livre avec vous parle de
l'onu au cambodge en employant les mots
jet set internationale en vacances quand
même droit il y avait un côté
de tourisme quand on a essayé de décrire
livre en voulait être honnête
puis on avait senti qu'on avait vu cchst
robes des massacrés et des génocides
dont il fallait mettre tous dans le
livre est en net sur lui-même sur l'eau
et nuccio nos chefs et les gourmands
alors oui c'est vrai tu sais plus rudes
été bien truquée très bon dans votre
bouquin et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait
aussi son succès aux états unis
si le sexe tient évidemment et les gens
qui travaillent pour l'onu ben oui c'est
comme tout le monde ils ont des
aventures alors il ya votre copain de
kent qui a des cas les conquêtes en
somalie parmi les membres féminins de
l'onu mais heidi alors elle ne se sert
chez l'habitant halal elles tapent dans
les locaux elle se tape un somalien qui
s'appelle lui souffle comme ça un jour
envie de baiser avec lui il faut
qu'elles baissent tout de suite c'est
assez c'est assez rigolo
elle se tape un masaï aussi elle part
sous la tente avec un masaï elle fume
des pétards pendant que pas combien de
temps en écoutant bob marley sous la
tente du masaï est lancée aux usa le
livre a été publié chez miramax book et
il s'appelle sexe en urgence et autres
mesures désespérées il va être bientôt
adapté la télévision c'est sa série
télévisée peu comme pour les années
ouais 90 ans bonne idée
bon je crois que ça peut être bien pour
le venue l'idée de ce livre c'est la
première fois que les gens par dans le
menu et bien qu de silence donc on est
censé ne rien dire ne vois tout ça peut
les génocides et des massacres des
guerres et ne rien dire alors la brise
et ses co de silence dans une
organisation très autoritaire et on a
été puni pour un mais
je crois qu'on l'a vu le meilleur et
le puits de l'onu et c'est tout dans le
livre c'est un très bon voilà ce qu'il
faut dire donc c'est important qu'on ait
une attitude consumériste par rapport à
des organisations comme la croix rouge
par rapport aux organisations comme
l'onu
c'est à dire que voilà on respecte
beaucoup ce qu'elles font ces
organisations mais en même temps c'est
ce que fait philippe gilbert ce que vous
faites vous en même temps on veut
pouvoir les critiques et on pourra leur
dire quand ça se passe pas bien parce
que c'est nous qui payons voilà je crois
qu'il faut critiquer cette organisation
pour que ça marche mieux
non au lieu de garder afin de rester
sinon voila merci docteur j'vais vous
libérer merci d'avoir accepté jeudi un
style disant merci beaucoup
oui
il dit
[Musique]
oui mais
j'accueille ingrid pedersen lennon
john avait une soeur cachée c'est vous
vous êtes la fille de julia giulia qui
était une épicurienne qui aimait prendre
du bon temps femme très joli mais qui
trompait allègrement son mari alfred
lennon le père de john qui avait le tort
d'être marin quand julia est enceinte de
vous alfred son mari est en mer et pour
éviter le scandale
elle vous confie ingrid à un couple
d'amis les pedersen dont l'homme peder
pedersen et sans doute votre père en
fait vous avez été adopté par votre
propre père d'une certaine façon
exactement les époux pederson faut
modifier votre état civil
vous devenez ingrid pedersen donc vous
êtes voilà vous disparaissez en tant que
fille de julian lennon
il ne vous parlent jamais du passé vous
passez donc les 11 premières années de
votre vie un liverpool à deux pas de
votre frère john lennon et de votre mère
julian lennon mais le silence est
assourdissant
vous commencez à éprouver de drôles de
sensations devait un sentiment confus
que quelque chose ne colle pas et un
jour vous demandez à votre mère si vous
êtes une enfant adoptée elle m'a dit non
elle ne m'a pas dit que j'étais adopté
mois alors les pedersen décide de
s'installer dans le kent et là vous
devenez une fan d'elvis presley caf ne
sachant pas que vous êtes là certes
jeune mais nan vous adorez elvis presley
les beatles vous en foutez en fait c'est
vrai je préférais vi
ouais et là dans le kent ne sera pas
très bien vous fumez votre première
cigarette à l'âge de 7 ans vous buvez
première vodka l'âge de 12 ans bientôt
vous ajouterez les tranquillisants en
réponse à des crises de panique s'est
amusé des crises d'angoissé très très
grave
sans savoir pourquoi en fait à ce
moment-là j'ai beaucoup de tension je
n'étais pas heureuse
j'étais dans une famille adopté il
régnait une grande tension
je savais qu'il y avait quelque chose
qui me tournait pas rond savais pas ce
que c'était exactement puisque ma mère
adoptive ne me l'a pas dit elle ne m'en
a pas parlé elle ne rien expliquer alors
vous rencontrez un homme vous décidez de
vous marier mais il vous faut un acte de
naissance donc vous écrivez à la mairie
de liverpool qui ne connaît aucune
ingrid pedersen et pour cause
et à ce moment là votre mère vous révèle
que vous avez été adoptée et que vous
êtes la soeur de john lennon à ce moment
là pourquoi est-ce que vous n'allez pas
voir john lennon quand vous savez le
jour où vous apprenez vous êtes sa soeur
pourquoi est-ce que vous n'allez pas le
voir je me suis allé parce que je ne
pouvais pas j'avais fait une promesse un
serment à ma mère des petits folie avait
dit que je ne chercherai pas john parce
que ça lui ferait trop de mains ouais et
je ne pourrai pas lui faire ça voilà
donc vous n'en parlez plus à partir de
là c'est fini vous en parler plus jamais
avec votre mère nous non plus jamais en
parler jamais alors pourtant john lennon
vous cherche un
il cherche à retrouver sa soeur
il me chercher sous le mauvais et cela
m'avait certificat en essence parce que
les deux avaient été changés voilà et
pourtant à cette époque john lennon est
présent partout et toujours dans les
radios dans les dents dans les journaux
vous commencez à lire tout ce qui a été
écrit sur lui vous vous préparer pour
une rencontre à ce moment là vous vous
pensez que vous allez l'appeler aller le
voir
oui j'espérais faire cela jamais pensé
qu'il pouvait être apte à signer je
voulais rencontrer je voulais rencontrer
mon frère et tous mais toute ma famille
mais je n'ai pas pu le faire à cause de
chapman qui l'a assassiné
et ça vous la prenez un soir à 19 heures
en regardant la télévision
vous êtes seul dans votre salon et on
annonce l'assassinât de john lennon par
mark chapman et là vous vous dites que
ce frère que vous n'avez jamais vu vous
le verrez jamais plus j'étais tout seul
était dans une autre pièce la même
maison elle est entrée dans le salon
elle
vu les infos à la télévision tout ce
qu'elle a dit ces pauvres k way sorti la
pièce c'est tout ce qu'elle a dit à ce
sujet et le jour vous apprenez la mort
de john lennon les journaux télévisés
parle de sa mère julian lennon et vous
apprenez en même temps que la mort de
votre frère la mort de votre mère
biologique qui est décédé en 1958 elle a
eu un accident de voiture en scène avec
45 ans et elle est décédée
petit à petit il mourrait l'un après
l'autre tous les membres de ma famille
et je n'ai pas pu rencontrer qui que ce
soit permis tout ce que je voulais
rencontrer
oui
par ailleurs
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'à la mort de votre mère
adoptive madame pedersen donc que vous
déciderez de lever le secret sur votre
sur votre origine
à partir de là vous n'avez plus aucun
problème pour en parler tout à coup je
me suis trouvée libre libre de faire ce
que je voulais faire depuis des années
et finalement toujours considéré comme
une enfant elle ne m'a jamais laissé
grandir et tout à coup je me suis
retrouvé avec le monde devant ma la
possibilité de faire tout ce que je
voulais et je les fais j'ai fait quelque
chose que je souhaitais faire depuis des
années alors quelques années plus tard
yoko ono vous invite à à new york
vous y allez elle veut elle vous montre
l'endroit qui s'appelle strawberry
fields ou les les fans de lennon
viennent déposer des gerbes de fleurs en
sa mémoire
et quand vous les voyez vous comprenez
que vous avez pas grand chose à voir
avec ces gens là finalement oui c'est
vrai je n'avais pas chose à voir avec
elle tout cas elle m'a pris un jour et
koné m'a dit que je voudrais me
rencontrer et donc
invitée à new york jallet de la
rencontre et dakota building john elle
vivait et puis elle m'a emmené sur leurs
fils à jo et puis elle m'a montré des
endroits où john et elle allait se
promener
je ne suis resté que deux jours denses
et est intéressant mais vous avez quand
même eu le sentiment d'avoir raté
également ce rendez vous là non la
possibilité de parler du coa tant que
j'aurai mais j'aurais voulu avec à voir
avec elle une conversation vraiment
intime s9 n'a pas été possible
[Musique]
elle avait toujours un chapeau avec elle
et contrôler à la fois des questions les
réponses
et donc c'était très difficile de parler
avec elle finalement alors aujourd'hui
vous vivez en france
vous vivez en maille s avec un homme qui
s'appelle john comme votre frère que
vous avez rencontrés quand vous étiez
toute petite à l'école à liverpool
je connais des filles puis autant que je
me souvienne il s'est marié de son côté
je me suis marié et puis on ne s'est
plus vu pendant un temps et nous nous
sommes retrouvés
c'est comme ça que ça doit se faire
c'est une histoire extraordinaire non
imagine imaginez vous auriez pas préféré
être la soeur de paul maccartney
finalement si vous aviez été la soeur de
ringo starr vous l'auriez pas d'y
[Rires]
répondre à cette question est-ce que
vous avez droit à l'héritage de john
lennon
je n'ai aucun droit
est ce que vous voyez julian lennon le
fils de john a eu avec sa première femme
rencontrée nigeria nation
j'adore aller rencontrer ce sont mes
neveux après tout ils ont vécu des vies
sera différente de la mienne
puis c'est une autre génération aussi
ils ne comprennent pas qu'on prenne pas
le pas c'est mon frère
éditions michel lafon
[Musique]
on passe aux blindes m
pour ce blind test jakl sabine
graissaguel 1
bonsoir ça joue soit animé le top 50 sur
le ciel oui à 16h45 fait d'autres choses
à la télévision oui ce qu'un magazine
société aussi sur france 3 région paris
ile de france nord pas de calais
picardie et normandie et s'appelle ça
nous regarde et se diffuser à 12h50 tous
les dimanches on va le regarder on va
être obligés maintenant toujours
regarder france 3 12h50 le dimanche
alors sur la normandie c'est par va se
lever de bonne heure à laurent bien sûr
qu'ils soient je vais m'asseoir et cette
bonne blague c'est cela oui mais je sais
pas vraiment mais voilà alors normal le
dj ce soir c'est guillaume selector
guillaume de saint phalle digium
selector voilà comment ça va j'ai besoin
de cela
avec toi voilà qui s'appelle comment de
cela n'est rien mais cabale et yo yo
d'accord alors c'est quoi le slam le
cinéma muet révolution dans l'histoire
de l'image
les vitraux un symbole puissant offrant
sa cabine aux dérapages prisonnière d'un
thomas que je surnage offrant
sporadiquement de l'air avait de la
matière à ma réflexion
je ne reste pas menti public est immergé
dans cette cuvette est propre aux
perturbations dans météorologiques
qu'idéologique
la logique objective mélange de
dogmatisme fait que les guerriers de
l'oral c'est là contre les récifs
esquisses de solutions devient alors
brouillon couillon quand il est question
de parole il est le champion
mais pour ce qui est de l'action en
temps faire des provisions des édiles ce
qu'il est et iris quality houthis qui
s'est tu crois qu'il estime ainsi voilà
un croisement
nogaro et dark vador
comment un sou l'erreur du slam la
bouche à zohra islam donc acteur 11 au
trabendo le dimanche 12 juin de 16h à
23h voilà merci beaucoup
en fait l'islam la poésie moderne
est ce que vous les jouez avec nous au
blind test bench chaque côté alors hein
vous connaissez le principe au début si
l'équipe de laurent ruquier contre
l'équipe de laurent baffie et après
c'est chacun pour sa gueule on y va y
sommes
tâche
on le sent la reprise oui
oui alors maintenant
cherchez bien dire ou bien donc un poing
volées
associé à catherine lara on continue
guillaume
oui xavi keita
auj
jal
je suis
un point partout bravo lankais mais je
vous en prie thierry avec mon petit
allons-y guillaume
[Musique]
je me suis
g
[Musique]
ben alors la soeur de john faut se
réveiller un faux nous aider on y va
attendons j'espère que non
[Musique]
bien ça nous fait trois points pour
l'équipe de laurent baffie il faut qu'on
se réveille ont réveillé un jour je
serai maintenant je jouais
maintenant je joue elle fait le top 50
elle devrait commencer en ce moment je
suis à 100
si deux blocs et sono et enfin
championne
non
[Musique]
placer le john lennon la nature de john
lennon elle l'écouté elvis presley au
lieu d'écouter les beatles et elle
savait pas qu'elle était la soeur de
john lennon
sinon leur ai dit c'est john lennon et
les citoyens sur en continu d'elvis qui
va sortir
si non ripley serge replay
davies qui va sortir
[Musique]
je crois que c'est la petite qui a
trouvé sa remplaçante en un point de vue
est ce qu'on lui dit de nom et qui était
évident
[Applaudissements]
rassurez vous c'est compliqué après ça
fait 3 3 bravo laurent tu remontes bien
grâce à mademoiselle bien ça le plus
remonté
oui c'est serré serré bien la chute non
moi
eh ben dis donc ça fait quatre combats
filles 3 pour eux qui est on se réveille
on serait là on y va y sommes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
diallo 4 4 ou là c'est chaud là on y va
y sommes dues
pour le cnt celle ci y avoir procès si
mauvais si la commande dans la city mais
qui de banquier
si on
le guern
dupré qui veut dire qu'une fois la soeur
de john lennon avec versailles allons-y
guillaume le dernier arrêt ouais
[Musique]
voilà donc à l'issue du par équipes nous
sommes à 5 5
bravo bravo à eux deux et qui est
maintenant nous passons au chacun pour
soi jeu l'équipe plus d'amis vous
connaissez le principe on il va me
sellini viol c'est dur
bon appétit
bravo
très bien ça c'est pas vous qui allez
trouver des lieux ghana car on continue
guillaume non
lens
ouais
[Musique]
béchard
mais le gars qu'est ce que tu écoutes
avec ton américains parce que vous
écoutez comme avant ça aussi ouais
d'accord on lui a pourtant envoyé
concours eurovision de la chanson a
nourri en plus alors on y va maintenant
c'est l'ultra bon quotidienne sur rina
ketty georgette lemaire c'est fini ça
c'est une époque où il y avait encore de
la chanson française mais encore c'est
ce que l'on regrette d'ailleurs qui est
plus chanceux qu'après une chance en
france alors mais tous les dj qu'on
invite cette année il met plus de
chansons françaises les mecs ils sont
tous deux chansons vous servez que
maintenant on arrive à l'ultra bon coup
celui ou celle qui va atteindre glattal
celui ou celle qui va trouver l'ultra
bon coup ce sera le roi ou la reine de
la soirée
attention vous êtes concentrés là tu
devrais trouver sinon ton boulot de top
50 à mcn scénariste de paris là c'est
quand même tu vas voir c'est quand même
un truc que tu dois connaître ça à temps
ah oui qu'est je suis pas sur mes toiles
11 il y sommes
tél
[Musique]
quand il l'a dit je suis désolé mais tu
juste citer mais virgin et c'est bien
quand même
je m'en serais on va regarder sur une
serre il assurerait sa place à sauver
son job
voilà alors qui a gagné finalement c'est
toi qui gagnes et bras au monde a changé
merci sommes donc bouche à oreille slam
trabendo le dimanche 12 juin de 16h à
23h voilà le star entrée libre le slam
de la poésie en fait non solution la
poésie d'aujourd'hui
absolument tout aussi simple que ça
merci c'était tout le monde en parle
matignon ce plan jean michel jarre
coffret dvd jon china
anne caillaud deadline le jury de cannes
mais michael heures
avec anne parillaud s'était noyé ça sort
le 8 juin
plus la bande originale du film à
jamiroquai l'album s'appelle dynamique
il sort le 20 juin est entouré le 21
juillet coop le jean et le craft de
juillet
laurent ruquier on va s'gêner les
meilleurs moments de son émission sera
pas s'est délité saison un repenti olga
kurylenko l'annulaire le gameplay à
trans avec olga kurylenko et marc barr
belge et le 8 juin salle catherine lara
l'album s'appelle fasse grand ciel le
single s'appelle petit homme viendra
gold race philippe gilbert les dames de
ceylan édition les équateurs robert sud
est de la france où il est devenu andrew
thompson il faut sauver la planète
c'est chez payot saluer nos si mon frère
s'appelait john lennon c'est et michel
lafon
le dj guillaume selector je rappelle
encore une fois bouche à oreille
cela va conduire à mon tour le 12 juin
2005 à partir de 16 heures on se crée ni
voyage et au blind test sabine
graissaguel dans votre peau dans le top
5 ans du lundi au vendredi à 16h45 sur
mcm
à bercy l'éviter
[Musique]
à
c'est quoi
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu